Can I just be shameless and say what I'm actually really excited for? Can I just say it? Yeah. I'm really excited for our live show. Oh. I'm nervous. I'm nervous. I always get nervous about it.
我能直话直说，说出我其实最期待的是什么吗？我能说吗？可以。我真的很期待我们的现场演出。噢。我很紧张。我很紧张。我每次对这个都很紧张。
Are you guys nervous about it? You're talking about the one that's coming up November 15th out there at the Hollywood Bowl? I'm very nervous about it. That's the one where people can go to smartlist.com slash live to get tickets. That's the one I'm talking about. Wait, what's the what's? It's smartless. It's where I would go if I wanted to buy a ticket to it.
你们大家不紧张吗？你们说的是11月15日即将在好莱坞露天剧场举办的那场吗？我非常紧张。就是大家可以去 smartlist.com 斜杠 live 买票的那场。我说的是那场。等等，什么，什么？是 smartless。如果我想买票，我会去那个网站。
That's where you'd go if you want it. But anyway, I'm nervous about it. Because it's going to be the Hollywood Bowl, and we've got a couple of good guests. I had a bowl of honeynut shirios for... Okay, great. All right. Let's get to an all-new smart list. What do you guys?
那是你想去的话就会去的地方。不过总之，我很紧张。因为那将是在好莱坞露天剧场，而且我们有几个很好的嘉宾。我吃了一碗蜜桃坚果脆麦片当……好吧，太棒了。好了。我们来开始一期全新的 smart list。你们觉得……
You know, when you're scheduling something. I've got a, I'm doing a pod, I'm doing a record. How do you refer to what we're doing right now when you talk to other people? I just record, I say record. I say record, I say record, or sometimes, or I'll say I have to record a smart list. Yeah, I got a smartless.
你知道的，当你在安排行程的时候。我有一个，我在做一个播客，我在做一档录音。当你们跟别人说话时，你们怎么称呼我们现在在做的事情？我只说录音，我说录音。我说录音，我说录音，或者有时，或者我会说我得录一期 smart list。对，我有一个 smartless。
It's a long version. I've said, I've said pod a couple of times, and it feels terrible. Yeah, of course it does. Well, sounds terrible. Yeah. Hey, what about the three of us get to put our chest and faces on each other on Sunday? for the first time in forever.
这是个长名字。我曾经说过，我说过几次“pod”，感觉太糟糕了。对，当然糟糕了。嗯，听起来很糟糕。对。嘿，我们三个周日能把胸膛和脸贴在一起，这感觉怎么样？这是永远以来的头一遭。
What do you mean? We're all going to have dinner on Sunday? Yeah. All right, good. I don't think Amanda's going on. Amanda's not. So I actually have an out. But I was thinking since you guys are going to be there.
你什么意思？我们周日都要去吃晚饭？对。好吧，很好。我觉得阿 Amanda 不会去。Amanda 不去。所以我其实有个借口。但我在想，既然你们都要去。
Well, you better be there. I'm going to be solo too this Sunday. So it's going to be. Really? So we're going to have, yeah. Jason, will you be? Yeah. Do you want me to wear something special?
好吧，你最好去。我这个周日也是一个人去。所以会是。真的吗？所以我们会有，对。Jason，你会去吗？对。你想让我穿什么特别的衣服吗？
Yeah. I want you to pick me up. I want you to pick and open my door. And I'm going to wear that thing that you. Yeah, that I was asked for. No, I got it. Hey, we saw, we missed you last night. I was over there, Willie, last night with Jay.
对。我想要你来接我。我想要你来挑衣服并帮我开门。然后我会穿那个你。对，我要找的那个。不，我找到了。嘿，我们昨晚看到你了，我们昨晚想你了。我昨晚和 Jay 一起在那边，威利。
Are you worried? Yeah, just for a quick bite. Quick bite. How was that? Yeah. It was good. Oh, good. Okay.
你在担心吗？对，就吃个便餐。便餐。感觉怎么样？对。挺好的。噢，很好。好吧。
Okay. Okay. Okay, good. So you guys had dinner? Well, we're having dinner tonight. That's right. Me and Willie are having dinner. You guys going to go to JAR?
好吧。好吧。好吧，很好。所以你们吃过晚饭了？嗯，我们今晚吃晚饭。没准。我和威利今晚吃晚饭。你们要去 JAR 餐厅吗？
It doesn't matter. Yes. How did you know that? Truly? Yeah. Yeah. You want to go or no? Well.
这不重要。是的。你怎么知道的？真的吗？对。对。你想去还是不想去？嗯。
Nah, we're going to see each other Sunday. You can come. Come. Thank you. It's going to be fun. Yeah, because I haven't hung out with Carolyn yet, really. Oh, sorry, can I say that? Oh, boy. Oh, well, the Internet's saying it, so I think we can.
不用了，我们周日会见面的。你可以来。来吧。谢谢。那会很有趣。对，因为我还从没跟卡罗琳一起出去玩过呢，真的。噢，抱歉，我能说这个吗？噢，天哪。噢，好吧，网上都在说，所以我想我们可以。
I don't know. Wait, what did we talk about last night, say? Oh, yeah. We talked about, hey, well, have you seen this alter ego thing? I was talking about at the table where it's a new device, it's like an AI device and you put it in the back of your ear. Yeah, listen to this. This sounds like a nightmare.
我不知道。等等，我们昨晚聊了什么来着？噢，对了。我们聊了，嘿，嗯，你见过这个所谓的“另一个自我”的东西吗？我当时在桌上说，那是个新设备，有点像人工智能设备，你把它戴在耳朵后面。对，听听这个。这听起来像是一场噩梦。
And all, whenever you, whatever you think of, it translates into audio. Audio. Yeah, audio text. You imagine that? Like basically having a microphone on in your brain? That's a nightmare. Yeah. But, I mean, only if you turn it on.
而且所有，每当你，无论你想到什么，它都会转化为音频。音频。对，语音文本。你能想象吗？就像基本上在你的大脑里开着一个麦克风？那真是个噩梦。对。但是，我的意思是，只有当你打开它的时候。
Like, you don't, it's not like you do. You know, I would, I would venture to say people would pay thousands and thousands of dollars to have that eliminated if that was something that was stuck on. Most people. Imagine. But it's, but it's, but it's. When things' thoughts were vocalized, the jails would be full. And they'd empty their accounts to get rid of it. Yeah.
就像，你不会，它不是那种你会。你知道的，我敢说，人们会花成千上万的美元来把这功能消除，如果那是个一直戴着的东西的话。大多数人。想象一下。但它是，但它是，但它是。如果人们的想法都被说出来，监狱就会塞满。而他们会倾家荡产来摆脱它。对。
But, I mean, it's volunteer. It's not like stuck to your head. No, I understand that. I'm just saying they're going to have a tough time saying, kill J.B, kill J.B, kill J.B, kill J.B. For this new device. That just sounds like a... I hope Jason misses this pot. I hope Jason misses this pot.
但是，我的意思是，这是自愿的。又不是粘在你头上的。不，我明白这一点。我只是说，他们很难说出“杀掉 J.B，杀掉 J.B，杀掉 J.B，杀掉 J.B”。为了这个新设备。这听起来就像一个……我希望 Jason 错过这一期播客。我希望 Jason 错过这一期播客。
Hey, did I leave too abruptly last night? No, you actually triggered a mass exodus. which was fantastic. We all left right after that. It was, you know. Wait, wait, what do we mean we all? What are we talking about? 15, 20, 25 people?
嘿，我昨晚是不是走得太突然了？没有，你实际上引发了一场大规模撤离。这太棒了。我们所有人都在那之后离开了。那真是，你知道的。等等，等等，我们说的“我们所有人”是什么意思？我们在说什么？15、20、25个人？
No, it's like eight, six people, eight people. What? Hang on a second. Pump the brakes. What was I left out of? This was a specific little bite. It's a bite and smile. It was a bite and smile. And I don't know these people.
不，大概八个人、六个人，八个人。什么？等一下。踩刹车。我被排除在外了吗？这是一个特定的小聚。这是一个小聚并微笑。这就是一个小聚并微笑。而且我不认识这些人。
Exactly. Not very well at all. Oh, okay. Yeah, that's right. But we also did. Yeah. You have a guest today. I do, I know.
没错。一点也不太熟。噢，好吧。对，没错。但我们其实也。对。你今天有一位嘉宾。我知道，我知道。
We're going to get right to it. I was going to share one more thing, but that... I'd love to hear it today. I'd love to... You worked on material. Go ahead. No, it's not. It's...
我们马上就要开始了。我本来想分享最后一件事，但那……我今天很想听听。我很想……你为此准备了素材。说吧。不，不是。它是……
Okay, here we go. No, no, no. Wait. I want to hear... No, no. It was just that... It was that topic, that whole thing about, you know,
好吧，我们开始吧。不，不，不。等等。我想听……不，不。只是……就是那个话题，关于，你知道的。
men and women and, like, sexual opportunities. So, like, I asked all the women at the table. Like, if a guy came to the door, and there was the best-looking guy in the world, would you... And he... you whether you know politely or impolately whatever was just based on looks would you go for it and of course unanimously every girl around the table was like no i would never i would never do that
男人和女人，以及，比如说，性机遇。所以，我问了桌上的所有女性。比如说，如果一个男人来到门前，那是全世界长得最好看的男人，你会……而他……不管你是礼貌地还是不礼貌地，随便什么，只是单凭外表，你会接受吗？当然，桌上的每一个女孩都异口同声地说，不，我永远不会，我绝不会那样做。
you can be much more specific than that you can you can you can say what the actual well it was it was like if a guy if a like dropped that gorgeous unbelievable guy was at your door and he just like exposed himself but not really like but like in a or answered in a robe or something and of course every girl was like no that's disgusting that's weird and bizarre And then, but conversely, all the gay guys and the straight guys were like, yeah, I would totally go for that. You know what I mean? Meaning if it was the opposite. If the door opened and a woman had her robe open, the guy would say, oh, yeah, cool if I come in.
你可以把细节描述得更具体一些，你可以，你可以，你可以说出实际的——嗯，当时的情况是，如果一个像那样帅得不可思议的家伙出现在你家门口，他就像是展示了自己，但也不是那种，而是在一件浴袍里或者什么的，当然，每个女孩都会觉得，不，这太恶心了，太奇怪太诡异了。然后，但反过来，所有同性恋和直男都会觉得，对，我完全可以接受。你知道我的意思吗？意思是如果情况反过来。如果门打开了，一个女人敞开着浴袍，男的会说，哦，太好了，我能进来吗？
Yeah. You know, as opposed to the, and I guess Sean was making a statement about the difference in sexes. It reminds me of this old joke to my grandfather. father had. And this is almost a dad joke, but it's worse. It's a grandfather joke, which is a guy's on a desert island. And he's there by himself for years and years and years. And this beautiful woman comes out of the surf, and she's wearing a wetsuit. And she says, when was the last time you had a nice cold beer? And he's like, oh, my God, it's been forever. And she reaches in their wetsuit, pulls out a beer. And he chugs it down. And she goes, when was the last
对。你知道，而不是，我想肖恩当时是在表达男女之间的差异。这让我想起我祖父讲过的一个老笑话。我祖父以前讲过。这几乎算是一个冷笑话，但还要更糟。这是一个爷爷级的笑话，讲的是一个家伙流落到荒岛上。他在那儿孤零零地待了整整好多年。然后一个美丽的女人从海浪中走出来，她穿着潜水衣。她说，你上一次喝到冰爽的啤酒是什么时候？他说，噢，天哪，那已经是好久以前了。然后她把手伸进潜水衣里，掏出一罐啤酒。他一口气喝光了。然后她说，你上一次……
time that you had a smoke? And he was like, oh, years. And she's like, pulls out of cigarette lights. And he's like, oh, my God, it's incredible. And then she looks at him and she goes, when was the last time you played around and he goes you got golf clubs in there that's a good one it's a grandfather joke what but shani told me a great grandfather joke a granddad joke they're really dad joke was it the cat yeah how do uh maybe sean should tell it i kind of punched up the reading a little bit better go ahead go ahead good uh what yeah so what uh No, it's what is it? How does a cat like its steak?
抽烟是什么时候？他说，噢，好多年了。然后她从潜水衣里掏出一支烟并点燃。他说，噢，天哪，这太不可思议了。然后她看着他说道，你上一次做那种事是什么时候？他说，你那里面带着高尔夫球杆吗？这个不错，这是一个爷爷级的笑话。什么？但是肖恩刚才跟我讲了一个很棒的爷爷级笑话，一个老爷子笑话，真的是冷笑话。是关于猫的吗？对。怎么——也许该让肖恩来讲。我刚才把语调稍微润色得更好了一点。说吧，说吧。好，什么？对，所以什么——不，是什么来着？猫最喜欢它的牛排怎么做？
Rare. Oh, my God. I can't even. It's so not even funny. All right. You got to have the little tiny claws up when you do it too. Oh, that'll help it. Yeah, that'll love it.
几分熟（Rare）。噢，天哪。我真是受不了了。这简直一点都不好笑。好了。你讲这个的时候还得把那两个小爪子翘起来才行。噢，那会有帮助的。对，那会很可爱。
Guys, we're so silly. We're over. We're over time already. All right, look, look, we got a guy here waiting. We just thank our guest now. We'll apologize first. He's a big deal, guys. I might geek out a little bit.
伙计们，我们太傻了。我们已经超时了。好吧，听着，听着，我们这儿有个家伙在等着呢。我们现在就感谢我们的嘉宾吧。我们先道个歉。他是个大人物，伙计们。我可能会有点激动。
I'm a huge fan. He was born in Guatemala, and then he kind of ping ponged around the United States. As a kid, while his dad finished his medical residencies, he almost joined the Marines before making a sharp pivot to Juilliard. He spent most of his teens in Florida playing bass and singing in a ska punk band, including one that opened for Green Day. but now he's one of Hollywood's most versatile actors playing everything from a folk singer,
我是他的超级粉丝。他出生在危地马拉，然后在美国各地辗转。还是个孩子的时候，父亲在各地完成住院医师实习，他差一点就加入了美国海军陆战队，后来急转直口去了茱莉亚音乐学院。他的青少年时期大部分在佛罗里达度过，在一个朋克乐队弹贝斯并担任主唱，其中还包括一支给绿日乐队暖场过的乐队。但现在他是好莱坞最多才多艺的演员之一，扮演过从民谣歌手、
mad genius tech guy, a rebel pilot, a superhero, a Shakespearean royalty. He's ridiculously talented, absolute joy to watch. One of my favorite actors of all time, Oscar Isaac. Whoa! Oscar!
疯狂天才技术宅、义军飞行员、超级英雄，到莎士比亚王室成员等各种角色。他才华横溢得离谱，看他的表演绝对是一种享受。我历来最喜欢的演员之一，奥斯卡·伊萨克。哇！奥斯卡！
He had an absolutely stumped. Oscar. See the closet out. I'm so telling my six-year-old this joke when I was told these cool things. You know what? Okay, rolling speed and action.
他彻底惊呆了。奥斯卡。把这个冷笑话收起来。当我听到这些酷炫的事情时，我一定要把这个笑话讲给我六岁的儿子听。你知道吗？好吧，开机速度和动作。
Let's see your reading on rare. He's like I can't. It's going to be hard to beat, man. It's going to be hard to beat. I think the claws are definitely necessary. You need the little kitten claws. Yeah, Sean's got great dad jokes. You got any dad jokes, Oscar?
让我们看看你对“几分熟”的演绎。他就像是“我不能”。这很难超越，伙计。这很难超越。我觉得小爪子绝对是必需的。你需要那些小猫爪。对，肖恩很会讲冷笑话。奥斯卡，你会讲冷笑话吗？
No, my heart's pounding. You guys are so fast and so funny. No, boring. It's so intimidating with your speed. need of wit. Oh, no, no, no. You should read what people say about me on this thing. They're so sick of me at some time.
不，我的心跳得好快。你们的节奏太快了，太搞笑了。不，好无聊。你们的语速和机智太让人有压迫感了。噢，不，不，不。你应该读读别人在这个节目里是怎么评价我的。有时他们对我厌烦透顶。
No, I'm sick of me. I'm really happy. You know, because there was a moment there. I remember during the pandemic where I think there was a moment where it's like, oh, can I come and do the show way back then? Oh, really? I was stuck down there. Yeah.
不，我自己都对我自己感到厌烦。我真的很开心。你知道的，因为曾经有一段时间。我记得在大流行期间，好像有那么一瞬间，我在想，哦，我能早点来参加这个节目吗？噢，真的是吗？我当时被困在那儿。对。
You've been on my list to be on the show since day one. Yeah, you've been on my list. But you have not stopped working on the greatest things that this business has to offer. since then and before. Yeah. Well done. I'm so, so happy every time I see you in something,
从第一天起，你就在我邀请上节目的候选名单里。对，你一直都在我的名单上。但从那以后以及之前，你一直没有停止过参演这个行业所能提供的最棒的作品。干得好。每次看到你参演什么作品，我都感到无比、无比的高兴，
I get more of you. And I just watched Frankenstein last night. You did? You did? What a second? You got home from the dinner and watched Frankenstein? No, I'm sorry, during the day yesterday,
我对你的了解就更多了。我昨晚刚看了《弗兰肯斯坦》。你看了？你看了？等等什么？你吃完晚饭回家就看了《弗兰肯斯坦》？不，不好意思，我是昨天白天看的，
not last night. Oh, thanks for the phone call. But wait, and we're going to get to that. But Oscar, holy moly, man. Your performance was incredible. I'm so excited to see that. I know. I mean, just incredible.
不是昨晚。噢，谢谢你的电话。但是等等，我们马上会聊到这个。但奥斯卡，天哪，老兄。你的表演太不可思议了。我很高兴能看到那个。我知道。我的意思是，简直不可思议。
I don't know how you do it. But anyway, listen, thanks for being here. I'm guessing when we met a couple years ago, you could probably feel what a big fan I was. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oscar, you described it from your side. What happened?
我不知道你是怎么做到的。不过总之，听着，谢谢你能来。我猜当我们几年前见面时，你大概能感受到我是多么大的一个粉丝吧。噢，不。噢，不。奥斯卡，你从你的角度描述一下。发生了什么？
No, it was at the awards dinner. Yeah, or no, it was, I think before that, it was the Lynn Manuel Miranda kind of things that he does in the street. Right. Right. And then we all had to, like, go out. If you're in a show,
不，那是在颁奖晚宴上。对，或者不，我想在那之前，那是林-曼努尔·米兰达在街上搞的那种活动。对。对。然后我们都得，比如说，走出去。如果你在演出，
he's erased that. Turns out he's erased that from his memory. I have a notoriously terrible memory with all things. I just feel like an over-stimulated moment like that, which was insane. Yeah, I know, me too. I'm like, so insane. But I remember at the, what was the award? I don't even remember what the...
他已经把那段抹掉了。原来他已经把那段从记忆中抹去了。我对所有事情的记忆力都出了名地差。我只是觉得那种过度刺激的时刻，太疯狂了。对，我知道，我也是。我觉得太疯狂了。但我记得在，那是什么奖？我甚至都不记得那……
Tony Awards? No, no, no, it was before that where everybody kind of has a dinner on a stage. Oh, yeah. How awkward was that? Yeah, yeah, there's a crowd, and then we're all on stage eating. Like we're on display? Yeah, and then you came over and said, I. Wait, wait, wait, sorry, I just want to put it.
托尼奖？不，不，不，那是在那之前，大家都在舞台上吃晚饭。噢，对。那有多尴尬？对，对，台下有观众，然后我们都在台上吃东西。就像我们被当成展品一样？对，然后你走过来对我说，我。等等，等等，抱歉，我只是想补充一下。
So you're all on stage eating and there's a crowd in the theater? It's watching you. Well, they're eating too, right? Okay. Yeah. Right? I think so. I don't remember.
所以你们所有人都在台上吃东西，剧院里有一群观众？他们在看着你们。嗯，他们也在吃东西，对吧？好吧。对。对吧？我想是的。我不记得了。
Meals on the last. I couldn't see them. I couldn't see them because there's lots of lights on. I mean, this is a new kind of dinner theater where everybody's eating, including the cast. And then let's get to Sean coming over and doing the offensive whatever it was. I'm sure it was. Was it about Dune? What was it about Star Wars?
末日大餐。我看不见他们。我看不见他们，因为有很多灯光。我的意思是，这是一种新型的晚餐剧场，每个人都在吃，包括演员在内。然后让我们说到肖恩走过来做出的那种冒犯的举动，无论那是什么。我敢肯定是。是关于《沙丘》的吗？是关于《星球大战》的吗？
Maybe it was a Star Wars thing. But we were on, you know, we were across the street from each other. You know, you were doing Oscar. You were the triumphant, the much celebrated play. I was doing the marginally tolerated play across the way, Sydney Brewsteen. And it was cool to be up there. That was my first time doing Broadway. And it was kind of by happenstance.
也许是个《星球大战》的事情。但我们在，你知道的，我们在街对面。你知道的，你在演奥斯卡。你演的是那部胜利的、广受赞誉的戏剧。我演的是马路对面那部勉强被容忍的戏剧，悉尼·布鲁斯汀。能在那里演出真的很酷。那是我的百老汇首秀。而且这有点像是个巧合。
Really? Yeah, yeah, because we were doing this. What about Hamlet? That was at the public. Oh, I didn't know that. Which is what, technically off-Broadway? Yeah, that's off-Broadway. Yeah, but anyway, I just, you know, a huge fan.
真的吗？对，对，因为我们在做这个。那《哈姆雷特》呢？那是在公共剧场。噢，我不知道。那技术上算外百老汇吗？对，那是外百老汇。对，但不管怎样，我只是，你知道的，我是个超级粉丝。
But I want to talk about, I had no idea you played instruments and, like, inside, oh, my God. Lewin. Yeah, Lewand. Incredible. Is that you really playing in the movie, too? Yeah. And was that a requirement that Cohn Brothers wanted?
但我很想聊聊，我不知道你会乐器，而且，天哪。勒温。对，勒温。太不可思议了。那真的是你在电影里弹奏的吗？对。那是科恩兄弟想要的要求吗？
They did. They actually were mostly, at first, they were just auditioned. I have no idea you were a musician. That's so crazy. Yeah, so I played, you know, I mean, I didn't play folk music necessarily, or like that kind of style. And so when I knew, when I heard that they were going to be auditioning for, I just really went in hardcore on learning like Travis Picking and doing all that. And it was, yeah, what's Travis Picking? Travis Picking is kind of like, it's almost like a ragtime on piano where, you know,
是的。实际上他们一开始主要只是试镜。我完全不知道你是个音乐家。这太疯狂了。对，所以我弹奏，我的意思是，我不一定弹民间音乐，或者那种风格的。所以当我得知他们要为这个角色试镜时，我就真的下苦功去学习“特拉维斯指法（Travis Picking）”并做到了这一切，而且，对，什么是特拉维斯指法？特拉维斯指法有点像，它几乎就像钢琴上的拉格泰姆，你知道的，
the left hand is doing the baseline and the right hand is doing. doing the melody. Shani, can you do it? Yeah, it's called stride piano. Yeah, stride piano, yeah. So you're kind of doing that with a guitar where the thumb is doing the baseline. Oh, really?
左手弹低音线，右手弹旋律。肖恩，你会吗？对，这叫跨越式钢琴（stride piano）。对，跨越式钢琴，对。所以你用吉他做类似的事情，大拇指负责低音线。噢，真的是吗？
These guys are just playing the melody. Oh, my God. Difficult? Man. Yeah, yeah, it's kind of like a, yeah, it's almost like the drumming where you have to kind of get some separation between the things. I saw you drumming in a music video yesterday.
这些家伙只是在弹旋律。噢，天哪。很难吗？老兄。对，对，这有点像，对，这几乎就像打鼓，你必须在不同事物之间找到一些独立性。我昨天在一个音乐视频里看到你在打鼓。
Is that, do you want to comment on that? What is that? Wait, was it the, was it the, it must have been a black rabbit adjacent music radio. Oh, right. Oh, that, yes. Yeah, it just popped up yesterday, and I just saw you hammering away on the skins. On your Instagram? On your Instagram. I see that. Yeah, it's a crazy thing.
那是，你想对此评论一下吗？那是什么？等等，那是，那一定是一个黑兔子（Black Rabbit）相关的音乐视频。噢，对。噢，那个，是的。对，它昨天刚弹出来，我刚好看见你在疯狂敲击架子鼓。在你的Instagram上？在你的Instagram上。我看到了。对，那太疯狂了。
I saw that from the first episode of that. You're so great. Oh, thank you. So you're so kind of, so effortless. Can I tell you last night, I haven't started it yet because I want to have a, I want to binge it all in a row. I think I'm going to watch it this weekend. And I had, but Bradley texted me last night. he watched until the final text was at 3.30 this morning. He sent me a nice test. I just finished Black Rabbit. It's incredible.
我在那部剧的第一集里看到了。你太棒了。噢，谢谢。你太好了，那么不费吹灰之力。我能告诉你吗，昨晚，我还没开始看，因为我想一口气连着看完。我想我这周末要看。而且我有了，但布莱德利昨晚给我发了信息。他一直看到今天凌晨3点半才看完最后一条信息。他给我发了一条很棒的信息。我刚看完《黑兔子》。太不可思议了。
It's unbelievable. And then he called me this morning. He's like, Bateman, literally, I'm not, this is not exactly. Bateman is an incredible actor. I can, yeah, I know. He did. That scene in the car with the coins and the reaction to the gun, be like, get it out of my face.
简直难以置信。然后他今天早上打电话给我。他说，贝特曼，说实话，我不是，这不完全是。贝特曼是个难以置信的演员。我可以，是的，我知道。他确实演了。车里和硬币在一起的那场戏，还有对枪的反应，就像，把它从我眼前拿开。
It was so funny and real. It was so great. I love that. He's so good. Oscar, back to you. I want to talk about your memory because I'm wondering if I have Alzheimer's or is it just us actors that, well, although Will is an anomaly, you can remember everything. He's Mary Lou Henner's brother. But do you think that our brains have morphed into a one trick pony where we can just remember lines and everything else it decides, I can't have this?
太搞笑太真实了。太棒了。我喜欢那样。他太优秀了。奥斯卡，回到你身上。我想聊聊你的记忆，因为我在想是我有阿尔茨海默病，还是只有我们演员会这样——不过威尔是个特例，你什么都能记住。他是玛丽·露·亨纳的兄弟。但你觉得我们的大脑是不是变成了一个只会一招的杂耍艺人，只能记住台词，而其他所有事情都觉得，我可装不下这个？
And it self-edits things that are not going to our bottom line. Like, I still, I still know all these Shakespeare monologues, but I can't. I think it's a, I think it's like, maybe it's like this anxiety. The moment there's even a slight doubt about a memory, it just erases or a person's name or anything. Like the second there's a hesitation, it goes. Do you have face blindness and all? I have a little bit of that where you're just like, I do, where I'm just like, Scotty, my husband, Scotty's like, you've met that person like 20 times. I'm like, really?
而且它会自动编辑掉那些与我们的核心利益无关的事情。比如，我依然，我依然记得所有这些莎士比亚独白，但我却不行。我觉得这是一种，我觉得这就像，也许这是一种焦虑。一旦对某个记忆产生哪怕一丝怀疑，它就会被擦除，或者一个人的名字，或者任何事情。就像只要有一秒钟的犹豫，它就消失了。你也有脸盲症吗？我有点那种症状，你会觉得，我有，我就会觉得，斯科特，我丈夫斯科特会说，你已经见过那个人20次了。我说，真的吗？
And it's horrible. It's a horrible thing. I think it is that thing. It's like a hiccup that happens. And then you're like, ah, it's like a paralysis. Yeah, I have a good memory, but I do have that too, Sean. It's not face-pliness, but I can't remember. People say we met or we know each other or we did the thing.
这太糟糕了。这是一种糟糕的情况。我觉得就是那种情况。就像是一个打嗝。然后你会觉得，啊，就像是瘫痪了。是的，我记性很好，但我也有那种情况，肖恩。不是脸盲，但我记不住。人们说我们见过面，或者我们认识，或者我们一起做过那件事。
It's awful. That part of my brain is completely cut off. But I can remember. But like, you know, like February of 2003, you can remember. Yeah, that's crazy. February 2003, I auditioned for, for, um, arrested development and that was in February
太糟糕了。我大脑的那部分完全被切断了。但我能记住。但是，你知道的，比如2003年2月，你能记住。是的，这太疯狂了。2003年2月，我去试镜，试镜了，嗯，发展受阻，那是在2月。
how would you Jesus like but like November 2018 you probably know what was going on yeah I do November 2018 I went to England for six days that's fucking crazy nuts yeah that is crazy I don't get that
你怎么会，天哪，就像，但比如2018年11月你可能知道发生了什么。是的，我知道。2018年11月我去英国呆了六天。这他妈太疯狂了，太神了。是的，这太疯狂了，我搞不懂。
the brain is amazing but then there are certain parts of it that I can't remember and I can also remember dialogue as well Oscar and I can remember also through I guess from like voiceover stuff over the years I can remember copy from voiceover campaigns that I did 30 years ago. Here comes the GMC tie-in guys.
大脑太神奇了，但其中某些部分我记不住，而且我也能记住台词，奥斯卡，我还能通过，我想是通过这些年来的配音工作，我能记住我30年前做的配音广告的文案。GMC的植入广告来咯，伙计们。
Well, no, no, no, I mean, he needs this morning. I did it this morning. Was anything professional grade this morning? Well, no, but you can get 0% in all, 2025 GMC terrain, 18 years. Good Lord. That river doesn't damn itself.
好吧，不，不，不，我是说，他今天早上需要这个。我今天早上才做的。今天早上有什么是专业级别的吗？好吧，没有，但你可以在所有车型上享受0%的利率，2025款GMC地形者，18年。天哪。那条河可不会自己筑坝。
Okay, Oscar, I want to talk about your, so not only did I not know that you played in a band and sang in a band in a band called the Worms, right? Nice. And then. One of the names of the bands. The Worms? What kind of,
好吧，奥斯卡，我想聊聊你的，不仅我不知道你曾在乐队里弹琴唱歌，在一个叫“虫子”的乐队里，对吧？太棒了。然后。乐队名字之一。虫子？什么样的高中，
music was it? Ska. Yeah, it was like Ska punk, right. Oh, boy, I can smell the weed from here. There we go. This was before, I wasn't drinking or, like, I didn't drink alcohol until, like, 24 years old. So I was, like, I was straight edge. Really?
音乐是什么？斯卡曲风。对，就像斯卡朋克，没错。哦，天哪，我从这里都能闻到大麻味。这就对了。这是在之前，我不喝酒，或者说，我直到24岁左右才喝酒。所以我当时是个苦行僧。真的吗？
I was, yeah, like, I didn't, so I was always the odd one out. But how did you go, how did you do that thing where you, because Sean said it in the intro, in eloquently, that you were in a band, and you were in Ska bands, and then you all of a sudden go to Juilliard. Was that one day, like, you're like, hey, guys, I'm out of the band, I'm going to Juilliard. Like, I'm not kind of. Really?
我是，是的，所以总是显得格格不入。但你是怎么做到的，因为肖恩在开场白里不怎么流畅地提到过你曾在乐队里，你在斯卡乐队，然后你突然就去了茱莉亚音乐学院？那是有一天，就像，嘿，伙计们，我退队了，我要去茱莉亚。就像，我不是开玩笑。真的吗？
For real? Well, a little bit. But you got it straight from Marines to Juilliard, which was, it was, yeah, yeah, I mean, a little bit. Wait, were you driving a moped with a raccoon tail on it when you play in the band? And suspenders, yeah. Yeah.
真的吗？好吧，有点像。但你是直接从海军陆战队去茱莉亚的，这，是的，是的，我是说，有点像。等等，你在乐队里表演时，是骑着一辆尾巴上挂着浣熊尾巴的轻便摩托车吗？还戴着背带，是的。对。
Really, I'll bet you were. I love, I remember those. How many times have you seen Quadrophina? No, sorry, keep going. Yeah, no, I had graduated high school. I was in this different band called The Blinking Underdogs. And we... Surprised that cleared.
真的，我敢打赌你就是。我喜欢，我记得那些。你看过多少遍《四重人格》？不，抱歉，你继续。对，不，我高中毕业了。我在另一个叫“眨眼劣势”的乐队里。我们……真不敢相信这名字能通过。
No one had that, huh? Nobody had it. They had the blinkers. They had the underdogs, but they didn't have the blinking. And just so you know, Oscar, I was in a band called Sounds from the Stairs. So it's all... All the names are... So keep going.
没人用过这个，哈？没人用过。他们有“闪烁者”。他们有“劣势者”，但他们没有“眨眼”。而且你知道吗，奥斯卡，我曾经在一个叫“楼梯回音”的乐队里。所以都是……所有的名字都……所以继续吧。
Yeah. Blinking underdogs. So many different band names. But, yeah, and so I came up. to New York to do this off, off, off, Broadway play. While you were in the band? Yeah, yeah. And we were touring, but Florida.
对。“眨眼劣势”。有那么多不同的乐队名字。但是，是的，所以我来到纽约来演这出外百老汇戏剧。你在乐队的时候？对，对。我们在巡演，但只限于佛罗里达。
We didn't really get out of Florida. And this was kind of as the third wave was cresting and kind of coming down of Scott, right? And when did you start closet heterosexuals? That was the third band. That was before Scott. That was hardcore. That was a hardcore band. Okay. That was hardcore.
我们其实没怎么离开佛罗里达。这差不多是在斯卡音乐的第三次浪潮达到顶峰并开始消退的时候，对吧？你是什么时候开始搞“衣橱里的异性恋者”的？那是第三个乐队。那是在斯卡之前。那是硬核朋克。那是硬核乐队。好的。那是硬核。
Okay, got it. That's good. Is that what you call it? And now you... Do you still collect guitars? Because I know you collect... Well, wait, Sean. Sean, he's telling you the story
好的，明白了。真不错。你管那叫硬核？现在你……你还收集吉他吗？因为我知道你收集……等等，肖恩。肖恩，他正在讲他去纽约演戏的故事，
about how he went to New York to do the play. What are we doing over here? Well, no, no, I went to do the play. And then I was up there, and I passed by Juilliard. And I was like, oh, Juilliard. Let me go in there and see what's up. And I asked... Come on.
我们在这儿扯什么呢？好吧，不，不，我是去演戏的。然后我在那儿，路过了茱莉亚音乐学院。我就想，哦，茱莉亚。让我进去看看怎么回事。我问了……少来这一套。
Yeah, yeah. And I asked for an application. And they said that the deadline was due already. This was like a Tuesday, and it had been due Friday. And I kind of like schmooze a lady. And I was like, can I... I'd just take it back. And she's like, well, take it.
对，对。我问他们要一份申请表。他们说截止日期已经过了。当时大概是周二，而截止日期是周五。我有点像是在对一位女士死缠烂打。我说，我能……我刚拿回来。她说，好吧，拿着吧。
Maybe you turn it in next year. And I went home that night, and I filled it all out. And I came back the next day. And she took it and, like, you know, post-a- What else did you have to do to get it? Was there an audition process? Yeah, then there was a whole audition process. Well, I had to come back and...
也许你明年再交吧。那天晚上我回家，把表全填好了。第二天我又回去了。她收下了，然后，你知道，贴了——你为了进茱莉亚还得做什么？有什么试镜流程吗？对，然后有一整套试镜流程。好吧，我得回去，然后……
Do like a monologue? Do a couple monologues and do, like, a movement class and a dance belt. Wow. Wear a dance belt or while you have anybody here. the afternoon. Did you ever You had that rare dance belt collection?
演一段独白？演几段独白，还要上形体课和穿舞蹈带。哇。戴着舞蹈带，或者在现场有谁在的时候。下午的时候。你有没有……你还有那个稀有的舞蹈带收藏？
Did you I don't have guitars but I have a great dance belt collection? Were you able to confirm that the other applicants had to wear the dance belt?
你有没有……我没有吉他，但我有一大堆出色的舞蹈带收藏？你能确认其他申请者也必须穿舞蹈带吗？
The funny thing no, the dance belt thing actually was not about the audition but the first day of when you got in they were like
有趣的是，不，舞蹈带这事其实跟试镜无关，而是你被录取的第一天，他们说，
this is what you have to do and I remember I went in with my dance belt and nobody else had put on a dance belt except for me we got another one got him
这就是你们必须做的，我记得我穿着舞蹈带走进去，除了我之外没有其他人穿舞蹈带。我们又钓到一个，搞定一个。
why would you put a dance belt on just for a monologue because that's my craft okay i got it okay i got it don't question we'll be right back and now back to the show um all right so what so will's point okay so but how did you where did you so you were in this band but you always had this kind of inkling to yeah i was doing plays i was doing plays in miami as well so i was doing both at the same time and where did the marines come in that was the guy the sax player of the worms
你为什么只为了一段独白就穿上舞蹈带？因为那是我的手艺。好吧，我明白了。好吧，我明白了。别问了，我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。嗯，好吧，所以，威尔的观点，好吧，但是你是怎么，你在哪个乐队，但你一直有这种倾向去……是的，我在演戏，我在迈阿密也演戏，所以这两样我同时在进行。海军陆战队又是怎么回事？那是那个家伙，那个“虫子”乐队的萨克斯手。
he and I just got really got his dad was a Navy SEAL and so we started talking about going in being getting like buff and you know and just like going in on the buddy system because you could do the buddy system at that time which is what what's the buddy system the buddy system is that you go in with a buddy and then you get to do all of basic training with your pal
我和他当时真的……他爸爸是个美国海豹突击队员，所以我们就开始聊参军，去练得强壮一点，你知道的，就打算一起通过搭档制度去参军，因为那时候你可以用搭档制度——什么是搭档制度？搭档制度就是你和一个搭档一起入伍，然后你们可以和好朋友一起完成所有的基础训练。
no way you get to do the whole thing so like that sounds great it just sounds rad I mean it sounds so fun right you gotta do pull-ups and push-ups and all this stuff like it's gonna be great and the thought that you even thought
真的假的？你居然能一起完成整套训练？听起来太棒了，简直酷毙了。我是说，这听起来太有趣了，对吧？你得做引体向上、俯卧撑这些乱七八糟的，感觉会很棒。而且你居然还觉得……
that you could like I would never occur to me I wouldn't even look it up because I'm like I'm not getting anywhere close to that right you're gonna get kicked out when you enter the barracks but then they're like
觉得你可以……这我根本连想都不会想，我甚至都不会去查，因为我觉得我根本不可能去那儿。你一进军营就会被赶出来。但接着他们说……
and then I said you know oh and I'll go in for combat photography I had watched you know full metal jacket and I'm like yeah like be a combat photographer and and so So we started doing the training, like you would meet up every weekend
然后我说，“哦，我要去当战地摄影师。”我当时看过《全金属外壳》，我想：“对啊，去当个战地摄影师。”所以我们就开始训练了，就像你每个周末都会去跟一些海军陆战队员汇合，做一些早期训练。所以你真去了？对，对。我甚至还去了，你得去一家酒店做各种体检和健康检查，然后进行你的第一次宣誓。还有一个第二次宣誓你得做。然后我……当我第一次报名时，我记得他们给了我一本小册子，里面列出了所有有名的海军陆战队员，比如那些富有艺术气息的海军陆战队员，像布赖恩·丹内利还有……
and start like doing the training with some of the Marines, like an early training. So you did that? Yeah, yeah. And I even went and I did the, you go to like a hotel and they do all like your examinations and health stuff and you take your first oath. And there's like a second oath that you have to do. And then I, and when I first signed up, I remember they gave me a pamphlet that had all like the famous Marines, like the artsy Marines, like Brian Dennehy and
我忘了他还有谁了。当时我觉得：“太好了。”然后我去签约，当我真的不得不去签约的时候，我本来打算以预备役身份入伍，我说：“我是来当战地摄影师的。”他们说：“哦，不，那是全职的。”我说：“那我能做别的什么？”他们说：“反坦克兵？”
I forget who else. And I was like, great. And then I went to sign up, like when I actually really had to sign up, and I was going to go in as a reservist. And I was like, I'm here for combat photography. They're like, oh, no, that's just full time. And I said, well, what can I do instead? And they said, anti-tank?
然后我想：“反坦克？怎么才能进坦克里？好吧，我得考虑一下。让我想想。”接着乐队里的萨克斯手退出了，说他和我已经不太亲近了。所以我失去了搭档，然后我们攒够了钱……然后我们攒够了钱……
And I was like, so against the tank? How do I get in the tank? All right, I'm going to think about that. Let me just think about it. And then the sax player quit the band and said he and I weren't really close anymore. so I lost my buddy and then we got enough money and then we got enough money
能在那个夏天录制一张专辑，录制我们自己的CD，所以我想：“我想我还是不去了吧。”哦，哇，所以你根本没有去参加基础训练？没有，我什么都没去。等等，但是后来你……
to record an album that summer to record our own like CD and so I was like I think I'm not going to do it right oh wow so you did not go through the basic training no I didn't go through any of that wait so but then you
所以我想回到之前的话题，因为我不知道你收藏吉他。那你到底有多少把吉他？我其实不收藏吉他。我是说我有几把吉他，但你跟科恩兄弟说你有。我打赌有七把，七把挺不错的。
so I want to go back to the thing because I didn't know you collected guitars so how many guitars do you have I don't really collect guitars I mean I have some guitars but you told the Cohen brothers you did I'll bet seven seven's pretty good
七把？七把吉他。那可真不少，这算是个收藏了。对。那是你最后一次试镜吗？我经历过的最后一次试镜是为《醉乡民谣》试镜。哇。
seven seven guitar That's a lot of guitars. That's a collection. Yeah. Was that the last audition? The last audition I ever did was for Hudducker Proxy. Whoa.
对。那是为科恩兄弟。我是说，我当时是为科恩兄弟读剧本。对。那是你人生中最后一次试镜吗？不。我最后一次试镜是为迈克·尼科尔斯。真的吗？
Yeah. So it was for the Coen Brothers. I mean, I'd read today for the Coen Brothers. Yeah. Was that the last audition you've ever done? No. My last audition was for Mike Nichols. Really?
哇。是为了百老汇的《背叛》。哇。哦，哇。对。哇。那是什么时候？糟糕透了。
Wow. For betrayal on Broadway. Wow. Oh, wow. Yeah. Wow. When was that? Terribly.
那是2014年。我记得我走进去时，听了很多哈罗德·品特的录音来模仿他的口音。我当时正在经历离婚，所以我就想：“天哪，我能感同身受。”我很清楚这个剧本，它很大程度上是关于……
It was a 20, 14. I remember I came in and I had like listened to a lot of Harold Pinter to kind of do his accent and I was going through a divorce at the time so I was like man I'm feeling this thing I'm aware of the play but it's very much about
那个、忠诚以及所有这些。所以我到了那里，朱丽叶·赖恩斯负责对戏。她是个非常非常优秀的演员，马克·赖恩斯的女儿。我演了第一场戏，然后……
that and fidelity and all that. And so I got there and Juliet Rylance was the reader. She's a great great actress Mark Vance's daughter and I did the first scene and
迈克·尼科尔斯很安静，他说：“你从哪学来这口音的？”我说：“我从哪学来的？”他说：“我从哪学来的？”我说：“哦，我在听品特的录音，听了一些录音，然后试着模仿。”他说：“哦，好吧，我想不同的英国人听起来是不一样的。”然后我们做下一场戏，所以我演了下一场戏。
And Mike Nichols was quiet, and he goes, where'd you get that accent? I was like, where'd I get it? He was like, where'd I get it? And I was like, oh, I was listening to Pinter. I was listening to some recordings and kind of trying to do that. He's like, oh, yeah, well, I guess different English people sound differently. And then when we do the next scene, so I did the next scene.
然后他说：“每晚都要演这出戏，会让你感到难过吗？”这是什么意思？我想：这是个陷阱题吗？这怎么回答？我说：“我只想实话实说。你知道吗？我来这里的地铁上还在读这个剧本，是的，你知道的，我最近正经历一些事情。”
And then he goes, would it make you sad to do this play every night? What is that mean? I was like, trick question. How do you answer that? I was like, I'm just going to be honest. Like, you know what? I was reading it on the subway ride over here. And yeah, you know, I'm kind of going through something right now.
我觉得我真的很能体会那种悲伤和痛苦，我觉得，是的，这绝对会……你知道的，夜复一夜地去剖析那些。然后朱丽叶·赖恩斯，上帝保佑她，她说：“但同时也很有趣，对吧？”我说：“哦，对，不，但同时也超级有趣。拜托，做这个，我可能和你们一样，会觉得超级有趣。”
And I feel really connected to like the grief of that and the pain of that. And I feel like, yeah, it would definitely be, you know, delving into that night by night. And then Juliet Rylentz, God bless her. She's like, but also fun too, right? I was like, oh, yeah, no, but also so fun. I mean, come on. Doing this, I'm probably with you. It'd be so fun.
对。然后他们说：“谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢。”然后我……对，然后我就走出去了。谁得到了这个角色？你记得是谁得到的吗？劳尔·斯帕。好吧。
Yeah. And then they're like, thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you. And then I, yeah, and then I walked out. Who got it? Do you remember who got it? Rave Spall. Okay.
对，劳尔·斯帕。他们把这部剧当成喜剧来演。哦。当成喜剧来演。所以正确的回答应该是相反的……对，正确的回答应该是相反的。但陷阱题的意思是，你只要告诉我，我想把它当成喜剧来演，所以，好吧，那会很有趣。
Yeah, Rief Spall. And they did the play, they did the play as a comedy. Oh. As well. So the right answer would have been the opposite of... Yeah, the right answer was the opposite. But the trick question is, just tell me, like, I want to do this at a comedy. So, yeah, okay, then it'd be fun.
对，我知道。你知道的，好吧，出生在危地马拉，这个我以前也不知道。还有巴尔的摩、新奥尔良、迈阿密。肖恩，这个问题会让你难过吗？会的。但同时也很有趣。我问这个问题的时候会玩得很开心。继续，继续。
Yeah, I know. You know, okay, so born in Guatemala, which I didn't. not know either. And then Baltimore, New Orleans, Miami. Sean, is this question going to make you sad? Yes. But also fun. I'm going to have a blast asking it. Keep going, keep going.
等等，你在六岁之前搬了那么多地方。为什么？因为你爸爸在……我看到的是他在做医学方面的什么。全是因为你爸爸吗？对，我是说，还有就是……对，移民的故事，你知道的，为了更好的生活来到美国。他在华盛顿特区长大。他是古巴人。
Wait, all that moving around before you were six years old. And why? Because your dad is, that's what I read, that he was doing his medical something. Is it all because of your dad? Yeah, I mean, also just like that, yeah, the immigrant story of like, you know, come into America for a better life. And so he grew up in D.C. He's Cuban.
他在古巴出生，但在华盛顿特区长大。后来他和两个兄弟一起去危地马拉学医。那就是他遇到我妈妈的地方。然后他们生了我姐姐。然后，对，然后我出生大约一周后——当时我六个月大——我们就先搬到了华盛顿特区，比如弗吉尼亚、巴尔的摩地区。我在那里上幼儿园，然后因为他去路易斯安那州立大学读住院医师，我们去了路易斯安那州，接着去了佛罗里达，我们在那边有亲戚，他妈妈也在那，我们和我的……
He was born in Cuba, but grew up in D.C. And then went to medical school in Guatemala, him and his two brothers. And that's where he met my mom. And then they had my sister. And then, yeah, then I was born in like a week as I was six months old. And then we moved to D.C. first, like Virginia, Baltimore area. I did kindergarten there, then Louisiana because he went to LSU for his, residency and then Florida where we had family and his mom was there and we live with my
奶奶一起住了一段时间，后来他终于成了一名医生。对，对。在你身上有没有什么压力，让你子承父业，还是说你完全拥抱了演员这条路？没有，他其实也算是一个有点失意的艺术家。好吧，他会和他的兄弟们用8毫米摄像机拍电影，好吧。你知道的，这也就是你最初灵感的火花吗？对，对，他会带回家……每个星期五都是电影之夜，他会带回这些神秘电影让我们看，然后他买了一台摄像机，我们就开始拍家庭录影带。所以当你涉足这一行时，他一定挺激动的吧？对，他挺激动的。他一直都很激动，直到我成了他的竞争对手。
grandma for a bit and then and eventually it became a doctor yeah yeah was there was there any pressure on you to to follow in his footsteps or do you fully embrace the the actor thing no he kind he was also a bit of frustrated uh artist no well like he would make movies with his brothers on a okay you know eight millimeter camera and that's what the initial spark was for you too yeah yeah he would like bring home every friday was like a movie night and he would bring home these like mystery movies that we'd watch and then he bought a camcorder and we'd make like home movies so he must have been kind of thrilled when you kind of got into this a little bit yeah he was into it he was into it until i became competition ah yeah is he still with us he's still with us
哈哈，对。他还健在吗？他还健在。
and so yeah i brought him to the frankestine premiere and oh no way oh that's so cool Which was good. Do you remember who the first actor was that he showed you that you kind of latched on to? I was like, oh, I'd like to have those chops when I'm older. Tim Curry. Yeah. Oh, really? That's cool.
所以，对，我带他去看了《科学怪人》的首映礼，哦，不会吧，哦，太酷了。那很好。你还记得他给你看的第一个让你深有感触的演员是谁吗？当时我想：“哦，我老了之后也想有那样的演技。”蒂姆·库瑞。对。哦，真的吗？太酷了。
Because I remember I saw, he showed, we watched Clue. Uh-huh. And then we watched Legend. Uh-huh. And when I realized it was the same fucking guy. What about Rocky Horror? Yeah, well, then, yeah, Rocky Horror after that. Although Dad didn't bring that one home for a movie night.
因为我记得我看过……他给我们看《妙探追踪》。然后我们看了《传奇》。当我意识到这两个是同一个混蛋时……《洛基恐怖秀》呢？对，好吧，然后……之后就是《洛基恐怖秀》了。虽然爸爸没有把那部带回家当电影之夜的片子。
Yeah. Yeah. but uh but man like i just i couldn't believe that that was the same guy and i noticed it because the way that his lip curled at one point as like the devil and you went like oh my god yeah oh you can whoa yeah yeah um what about i don't have to jump around sorry but what about how about cuba i've always been fascinated with cuba have you have you been able to go to go there since your dad has roots i haven't been i haven't been you know like i grew up in miami cuban world which is like everyone's so traumatized and afraid and so complicated, but I've wanted to go.
对。对。但是，天哪，我简直不敢相信那是同一个人，我注意到这一点是因为他有一次嘴唇上翘的样子，就像恶魔一样，你当时就想：“哦，天哪，是啊，哦，你可以，哇，是啊，是啊……”呃，关于——我不是非要转移话题，抱歉，但古巴呢？我一直对古巴很着迷，自从你父亲有那里的根基之后，你有去过那里吗？我没去过，我没去过，你知道的，我是在迈阿密古巴人的世界里长大的，那里每个人都受过创伤，充满恐惧，情况非常复杂，但我一直想去。
We almost went, when Lewin Davis came out, actually, we were going to go to the film festival, and then at the last minute it didn't happen, but it's definitely a place I want to go. What is the current? I feel so dumb, as usual. You can't, you can't go there freely? He's opened up for a moment. Yeah. Really? And then closed up and now.
我们差点就去了，实际上，当《醉乡民谣》上映时，我们本打算去参加电影节的，结果最后一分钟没去成，但那绝对是我想去的地方。现在的状况是怎样的？像往常一样，我觉得自己好蠢。你不能，你不能自由地去那里吗？他开放过一阵子。是啊。真的吗？然后又关闭了，现在……
It's closed again. Well, like, as an American, like Canadians go, I know that a lot of Canadians go there on holiday all the time. There are lots of flights, and I know. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right. To Cuba? Yeah. I mean, why would you want to go? Like, because it's beautiful?
又关了。嗯，就像，作为一个美国人，加拿大人去那儿，我知道很多加拿大人经常去那里度假。有很多航班，而且我知道。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，没错。去古巴？是啊。我是说，你为什么想去？比如，因为那里很美？
Oh, there's our quote for the day. There's, Sean. I mean, fuck you. Enjoy your vacation. I mean, it's an incredible play. How many demographics are you trying to get rid of it one, man? You don't. I just didn't know what the draw was.
哦，这就是我们今天的名言。肖恩，这就是你。我是说，去你的。享受你的假期吧。我是说，这是一部不可思议的戏剧。你到底想在一瞬间甩掉多少个阶层的人，老兄？你不会的。我只是不知道吸引力在哪儿。
Like, I know what the draw is. Put the shovel down. It's got an incredible culture. It's got. Okay, okay, okay. I just didn't know what the draw is. Hey, I can't wait to go to Cuba. All right.
就像，我知道吸引力在哪儿。别挖了。那里的文化太不可思议了。那里的……好吧，好吧，好吧。我只是不知道吸引力在哪儿。嘿，我等不及要去古巴了。好吧。
They feel the same way about you and the mall. What does he go to the ball all the time? Okay, so anyway, Oscar. So I grew up super, super Catholic. You grew up very, is it safe to say, evangelical or Christian? Evangelical, yeah. Evangelical. Now, let's get into religion.
他们对你和商场的看法也是一样的。他是不是经常去那个球场？好吧，不管怎样，奥斯卡。所以我是极其极其天主教的环境下长大的。你是在非常——可以这么说吗——福音派或基督教的环境下长大的？福音派，对。福音派。现在，我们来聊聊宗教。
No, I think it's fascinating because, you know, because you were like devout, right? We're talking to spiritual abuse. Yeah, totally. Totally. I love talking about it. We don't have to talk about it, but I love talking about it. Do, do. Because I don't, I know zero about religion. Please. Yeah, I, I mean, you know, it's, there's some wonderful Catholics, there's some wonderful Christians, and then there's the ones that are beyond hypocritical. But do you guys know, like, what is the difference between Catholic, Christian, evangelical, Episcopalian, Protestant, Methodist, Lutheran? They're all Christian. They're all under this big umbrella of Christianity, right? But how, what is the, is there a singular difference that, that separates each one of them, like, as far as interpretation of the Bible goes, or yes? Yes. Yes.
不，我觉得这很迷人，因为，你知道，因为你以前很虔诚，对吧？我们正在谈论属灵虐待。对，完全是。完全是。我喜欢谈论这个。我们不一定要谈论它，但我喜欢谈论它。当然，当然。因为我对宗教一无所知。请吧。是啊，我的意思是，你知道的，有一些很棒的天主教徒，有一些很棒的基督徒，然后还有那些虚伪到极点的人。但是你们知道吗，天主教、基督教、福音派、圣公会、新教、卫理公会、路德会之间有什么区别？它们都是基督教。它们都属于基督教这个大家庭，对吧？但是，如何……它们之间有没有一个单一的区别，比如就对圣经的解释而言，把它们各自区分开来，还是说有的？有的。有的。
Yeah, I guess that's a short answer. It's kind of complicated. But is it like an identify, like, could it be a jeopardy question? Like, what is the single difference between Lutheran and Episcopalian? Is there one teacher? Well, like, the Episcopal Church came from, is Church of England, right? And it was established as a sort of an offshoot of Catholicism. because Henry the 8th wanted to be able to divorce his wife.
对，我想简短的回答是有的。这有点复杂。但它就像是一个身份标识吗，比如，它会是一个危险边缘问答题吗？比如，路德会和圣公会之间唯一的区别是什么？只有一个导师吗？嗯，就像，圣公会起源于英国国教，对吧？它建立之初是天主教的一个分支。因为亨利八世想要和他的妻子离婚。
Jesus Christ. So he established the Church of England. And Martin Luther comes along. And then, so of course it's a little bit different. It's kind of like a lot of people describe Church of England as sort of Catholic light without all the pageantry. That's sort of a simplistic view. And then there are all these different, yeah. Yeah, and Catholicism, there's a lot more intercessors, I guess, as a word.
耶稣基督。所以他建立了英国国教。然后马丁·路德出现了。然后，所以它当然有点不同。很多人把英国国教形容为某种“清淡版的天主教”，没有那么多浮华的仪式。这算是一种比较 simplistic（过于简单）的看法。然后还有所有这些不同的，是的。是的，在天主教里，有更多中间人，我觉得可以这么说。
You know, like the saints and people that you pray to and like you said, the pageantry, which, to go to. Frankenstein is a very Catholic Mexican... Look at this pro. But he talks about it very much in that way, you know? A lot of Christ figure, like the forensic nature of the crucifixion. How about in the movie, when the monster was up on the thing, it was just shy of being a cross. I mean, definitely, no, we called it the crucifixion.
你知道的，就像圣徒和那些你向其祈祷的人，正如你所说的那样浮华的仪式，去到……弗兰肯斯坦是一个非常墨西哥天主教风格的……看看这个专业人士。但他的谈话方式非常带有这种色彩，你知道吗？有很多基督的意象，比如受难记的法医性质。电影里当怪物站在那个东西上面时，它离十字架只有一步之遥，不是吗？我的意思是，绝对的，不，我们称之为受难。
There's even a thorn, you know, the metal thorns on the head. No, totally. I thought it was cool. But was that a conscious choice of Guillermo or whoever to not make it a specific cross, but just at an angle. Have it a little bit. Yeah, you know what I mean? Yeah. I caught that.
甚至还有荆棘，你知道的，头上的金属荆棘。不，完全是。我觉得这很酷。但这真的是吉尔莫或其他人的有意识的选择，不把它做成一个特定的十字架，而是带有一个角度？让它稍微倾斜一点？是的，你懂我的意思吗？是的。我注意到了。
It wasn't an accident. Now, is working with Guillermo del Toro everything that you would hope and think that it is? He just strikes me as just such an infectiously enthusiastic and kind leader, not to mention his creative abilities are just unmatched. Yeah. Yeah, it was, it was, I had. I was like a kid. There was just so much joy.
这不是偶然。那么，与吉尔莫·德尔·托罗合作，是不是达到了你所希望和想象的一切？给我的感觉，他是一个极具感染力的热情、善良的领导者，更不用说他的创作能力简直无可匹敌了。对。是的，确实是，我有。我当时就像个小孩子。有太多的快乐了。
It was so much, so much fun. It was this particular approach to it too. Well, he was writing it. He's like, I'm Cabrona, I'm making you a banquet. And he really did. It was just like a feast of stuff to do every day. We only spoke in Spanish to each other. Oh, that's cool.
太棒了，真的太有趣了。这也是一种特别的创作方法。嗯，他当时在写剧本。他就像是在说：“卡布罗纳（Cabrona），我要为你办一场宴会。”他确实做到了。每天都有各种各样好玩的东西，就像是一场盛宴。我们俩之间只用西班牙语交流。哦，那太酷了。
He would direct in jokes mostly, like dirty Mexican jokes. But also, like, and he was just. a ebullent, really funny. There was no whispering behind monitors. You know, it's like if there was a problem, everybody knew it. If something was great, everybody knew it. Oh, that's amazing. It was just really, really fun. He would, and
他主要用笑话来指导，比如脏脏的墨西哥笑话。而且，像，他就是……热情洋溢，真的非常搞笑。监视器后面没有任何窃窃私语。你知道的，如果出了问题，每个人都知道；如果有什么地方很棒，每个人也都知道。哦，那太棒了！真的，真的非常有趣。他会，而且
it's like, zero pretension whatsoever. You know, he'd be like, uh, gavron, I need a lot of hamon on this one. He's like, just chamon with mustard and mayonnaise to make it go down easy. I just need you to look up and look right past the camera and
就好像，完全没有任何装腔作势。你知道的，他会说：“呃，加夫龙（gavron），我这个需要很多火腿。”他会说：“只要加火腿、芥末和蛋黄酱，让它容易下咽就行。我只需要你抬头看，看着镜头正上方，然后
hold it. Or there you or he'd be like, I I need you to do the Maria Cristina, which is like a telenovela thing. You know, he's like, I need you to be in profile and then walk across a counter to him and then stop and turn around and look. Right, super dramatic. You know, he's like, just give it to me,
保持住。”或者你会听到他说：“我需要你来一段玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜（Maria Cristina），就是那种肥皂剧的风格。”你知道的，他会说：“我需要你侧对镜头，然后从柜台前向他走去，接着停下来转身注视。”对，超级戏剧化。你知道的，他会说：“就把这个交给我吧，
give this, make this one Mexican happy, you know? Wow. I love that. The scope of the movie is so massive. Like, how long was the shoot? I mean, it spanned nearly eight months. with where was it there was a two-month break
让这个墨西哥人开心一下，好吗？”哇。我太喜欢了。这部电影的格局太宏大了。比如，拍摄周期有多长？我的意思是，它跨越了将近八个月。其中在什么地方……中间有一个月的假期
where he shot miniatures in London we shot it in Toronto and in the UK Scotland and do you when you do something like that with a director like that who has such a vision
他在伦敦拍摄微缩模型，我们在多伦多、英国苏格兰进行了拍摄。当你和这样一位有着如此宏大愿景的导演合作时，
right and he has a such a but from what I understand from you also a very collaborative spirit do you not to get sort of to but do you when you are in that
对吧，他有着……而且据我所知，你觉得他也有非常强烈的合作精神，当你处于那种状态时，为了避免变得太……但是当你处于
your ability what are the sort of the parameters or are there any of of sort of bringing stuff in your thoughts and feeling like you can just go out on a limb with a guy like him is it just pretty wide open in that way? It is
你的能力之中时，有哪些参数，或者说有没有什么参数，可以把你的想法和感受带进来，让你觉得可以和这样一个人一起大胆尝试，这种方式在很大程度上是完全开放的吗？确实是
like that was the one thought when I was going into it like I know he's an animator I know like the visual language is so precise and so I you know I went in expecting like all right the constraints are going to be tight but that's that that's the job but uh he actually was in in a very different i he he talks about like making
这样的，当我刚开始加入时，我唯一的想法就是：“我知道他是一个动画师，我知道视觉语言是如此精确。”所以，你知道的，我当时进去的时候心想：“好吧，限制一定会很严格，但那就是工作。”但实际上，他的情况非常不同，他谈论到
the movie with bradley really shifted him like it really opened him up in like an amazing way and you credit nightmare alley yeah nightmare alley he credits him a lot with like just him learning how to listen to the movie he would talk a lot about that while we were shooting it just like the movie kind of tells you what it needs in fact at one point i was saying like i don't you know i'm i find myself like am i not shaking it up enough am i not like being kind of dangerous enough and going out on a limb enough and he's like no that's that's an idea it's like the movie kind of tells you what it needs and however you're responding is what it's needing and if it's needing you to be this way then then don't second guess that so much yeah he gave a lot of feeling to all of us of like you
和布拉德利一起拍电影真的改变了他，真的以一种惊人的方式让他敞开心扉。你把这归功于《玉面情魔》？对，《玉面情魔》，他把很多功劳归于这一点，就是他学会了如何去倾听电影。我们在拍摄时，他经常谈论这一点，比如电影本身会告诉你它需要什么。事实上，有一次我说：“我不知道，你知道的，我发现自己……我是不是没有做足够的改变？我是不是不够具有危险性，不够敢于冒险？”他说：“不，那只是一个想法。电影会告诉你它需要什么，你做出的任何反应都是它所需要的。如果它需要你成为这样的人，那就不要对它产生太多怀疑。”是的，他给我们所有人的感觉就是
can't fail i wrote this stuff for you it's there's nothing to like reach for right which was great. And also, but also it was a very, it's a very specific kind of performance. He said you know, it's not naturalistic, it's heightened, I want speed of language, speed of thought, there's not a lot of pausing
你不会失败，这些东西都是为你写的，没有什么需要刻意去够的东西，对吧？这太棒了。而且，不过这也是一种非常、非常特殊的表演风格。他说你知道的，这不是自然主义的表演，它是夸张的，我想要语言的速度，思维的速度，你们没有多少时间可以暂停。
for you guys. It's kind of high camp and high melodrama and just all heart. Like that's what he wants it to be in a while. So he was really specific about the tone before you guys got started. Yeah, that's helpful. God, that's really helpful.
这有点像高级坎普风（high camp）和高级情剧（high melodrama），而且全都是真情实感。这就是他在一段时间内想要达到的效果。所以在你们开始之前，他对于基调非常明确。是的，这很有帮助。天哪，这真的很有帮助。
bet for sure um did he did he did the attempt to sort of give you a taste for that collectively by doing any sort of like table reads ahead of time or rehearsals in a group on like around a table no he didn't want to do that so much we had we did have one big table read uh with like the execs and all that uh and that was it i mean he you know because he was quite protective of the script as he was writing it um you know i think partly out of just like a little little insecurity as well. Like, I'm not sure it's quite there yet. And so he kept adjusting.
肯定的。呃，他有没有尝试通过提前进行任何形式的围读剧本，或者在桌子周围进行集体排练，来让你们集体感受一下这种风格？不，他不太想那样做。我们确实有一次大型的围读剧本，有高管们等等参加，然后就没了。我是说，你知道的，因为他在写剧本的时候对剧本保护得相当严密，你知道的，我想部分原因也是出于一点点的不安全感。就像是：“我不确定它是不是已经完全准备好了。”所以他一直在调整。
I mean, every day he was working. Like, even behind the monitor, he was drawing his storyboards. He would be quilting the movie as we went along. Like, sometimes you would do a take, and he would, like, put it right into the flow of the edit, so he would just show you. Like, we did the last scene of the movie, and the next day he came in with, you know, Johann Johansson music on it and showed the edited scene to me. How did you like that, or how did it affect what you were doing?
我是说，他每天都在工作。甚至在监视器后面，他也在画他的故事板。随着拍摄的进行，他一直在缝合这部电影。有时候你拍完一个镜头，他就会立刻把它放进剪辑流里，然后他就会直接放给你看。比如我们拍了电影的最后一场戏，第二天他就带着约翰·约翰松（Johann Johansson）的音乐走过来，把剪辑好的场景放给我看。你觉得怎么样？或者说它对你的表演有什么影响？
Well, I mean, that example in particular was interesting because, you know, it was the last scene of the movie. And so I want to try to talk about it without giving too much a way of it. It's like a highly emotional crescendo of the whole thing. And, you know, I spent the day, like, in the zone, like listening to all my sad sack music and, you know, like, looking at pictures of sad times, you know, doing like the full anti-mic Nichols,
嗯，我的意思是，那个例子特别有趣，因为，你知道，那是电影的最后一场戏。所以我想尽量在不剧透太多的情况下谈论它。这就像是整部电影的高潮，充满了高度的情感。而且，你知道的，我花了一整天的时间，进入那种状态，听所有悲伤的音乐，你知道的，看一些悲伤时期的照片，你知道的，做着完整的反迈克·尼科尔斯（anti-Mike Nichols）
moment and right this is in the arctic this is yeah in the ship yeah and you know and like did you know and i went in and like didn't talk to anybody and lay down we did this scene and there was tears and everybody was really happy and gearma was you know high five and all right we got it and then the next day he showed it to me and i was like i don't i don't really buy it
式的时刻。对，这发生在北极，对吧，在船上，对。你知道的，就像……你知道吗？我走进去，谁也没搭理，躺了下来。我们拍了这场戏，现场有泪水，每个人都很高兴，吉尔莫也击掌庆祝：“太好了，我们拍到了！”然后第二天他把成品放给我看，当时我就想：“我不，我真的不太买账。”
like me i was like was that take five i thought take five was the good take he's like let's take five covered on i was like i don't take us take five and then we looked and it wasn't take five but then take five wasn't that much better either was it because you think that you came in with too much of that too much of this and not listen to this check out check out what happened so then then then then uh i said i was sitting there and then game oh comes over he's like what's wrong i was supposed to just do like a little insert of my hand right grabbing his hand and he's like what's wrong i'm i don't know man i'm feeling a little insecure and he's like well you are an actor i was like i know i know but but i just feel like should
就像我当时心想：“那是第五条吗？我觉得第五条挺好的呀。”他说：“我们用的是第五条，卡布隆（cabrona）。”我说：“我觉得这不是第五条。”然后我们查了一下，确实不是第五条，但第五条其实也没好到哪里去。是因为你觉得自己当时带着太多的……带着太多的情绪进去，而没有去倾听这个？看看，看看发生了什么。所以然后，然后，然后，呃，我坐在那儿，吉尔莫走过来问：“怎么了？”我本来只需要拍一个特写镜头，拍我的手去抓他的手，他问：“怎么了？”我说：“我不知道，老兄，我感觉有点没有安全感。”他说：“你可是个演员啊。”我说：“我知道，我知道，但我只是觉得——”
I looked up maybe when I said sorry? Should I have, I just don't. And he's like, no, no, no, no. Those are all ideas. You know, you were honest and you thought about your mom and you thought about all these things and that was there. I was like, all right, okay. And then I went away for like 30 minutes and I was like, oh, I just have to be a dead body for the rest of the day. And I came back and he had set up a whole different thing.
“当我道歉的时候，我是不是应该抬头看一下？我是不是应该……我就是不知道。”他说：“不，不，不，不。那些都只是想法。你知道的，你刚才很真诚，你想到了你的妈妈，你想到了所有这些事情，那些情绪都在那里。”我说：“好吧，好吧。”然后我走开了大约30分钟，心想：“哦，我今天剩下的时间里只需要扮演一具尸体就行了。”当我回来时，他已经布置好了一个完全不同的场景。
And I was like, what are we doing? He's like, we're going to do it again. We're going to do your close up again. And he's like, you know what? From yesterday. And he's like, you know what? It's okay. Like, we're going to see if, you know, we definitely have something.
然后我问：“我们这是在干什么？”他说：“我们要重拍一次。我们要重新拍你的特写镜头。”他说：“你知道吗？就接着昨天的拍。”他说：“你知道吗？没关系。我们要看看，你知道的，我们肯定能拍出点东西。”
if you don't have anything, that's okay. I'll just make fun of you for the rest of your life. You know, win, win. And so, like, really quickly, I'm, like, throwing on my ear pods to try to, like, find a song to get me sad again. You know, like, I'm trying to do all the shit. And I just, I didn't have any time. I, like, lay down, and we did it.
“如果你什么都没拍出来，也没关系。我会在你余生里一直拿这个嘲笑你。”你知道的，双赢。所以，像这样，非常快地，我戴上AirPods，试图找一首歌来让我重新悲伤起来。你知道的，我试图去做所有这些狗屁事情。我根本没有时间。我躺下，然后我们就拍了。
And we did, like, four takes, and it was way better. Just, like, I wasn't. I didn't have time to try to, like, evoke anything. Yes. Or, like, it was, like, more sober. It was more severe. It just was, like, it was. You didn't have to bring a.
我们拍了大约四条，效果好多了。就像是，我没有时间去试图唤起什么情绪。是的。或者说，感觉更加清醒了，更加严厉了。它就是……你不需要带入一个
preconceived idea of what it should be as opposed to just letting it be. Yeah, and that's what's what's in the film, you know. I love that. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. So, but that adjustment in your performance came as a result of you watching what you were doing. And are you good about that? Because I'm sure you've worked as many actors as we have.
事先构思好的、它应该是什么样子的想法，而是任由它自然发生。是的，这就是电影里呈现出来的效果。我太喜欢了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。所以，但你表演中的这种调整，是你观看了自己的表演之后产生的结果？你对这件事拿捏得好吗？因为我确信你和我们合作过的大多数演员一样……
But some actors, they just, they don't watch. themselves they can't watch themselves i learned so much from seeing how bad i am sometimes it's like oh don't do that anymore or you think it's coming across this way but it actually comes across that's funny because i asked christoph waltz who's on it right it's like a fucking legend i asked him specifically about that and he's like he doesn't watch he's like because it's okay if you watch and you think it's not good but the bad thing is when you watch and you think it's good yeah and like that can be way worse why because then it's cut together and you're like oh maybe it wasn't that great.
但是有些演员，他们就是不看自己的表演，他们无法观看自己。从看到自己有时有多糟糕中，我学到了很多。这就像是“别再那样做了”或者“你以为自己表达的是这种效果，但实际上呈现出来的是那种效果”。这很有趣，因为我问过克里斯托弗·瓦尔兹（Christoph Waltz），他也在上面，对吧？他简直是个他妈的传奇人物。我专门问过他这件事，他说他不看。他说因为如果你看了，觉得演得不好，那还行；但糟糕的是，当你看了之后觉得演得很好。对，那就更糟了。为什么？因为随后这些镜头会被剪辑到一起，然后你会想：“哦，也许其实没那么好。”
Or there's just like a self-consciousness or you think, you know, it's just for him. But this was, but there's many times when I've watched something and I'm like, I can do it better and I just, and I can't, you know, it's in, so I don't know, man, I don't know. But that was, there was a moment there after that happened and I was like, well, this is I mean I have to watch every fucking take or every scene. Right, right, right.
或者只是会有一种自我意识，或者你会觉得，你知道的，这只是针对他个人的。但这种情况是，有很多次我看了某些片段后会想：“我可以演得更好”，而我却做不到，你知道的，它已经成定局了。所以，我不知道，老兄，我不知道。但当时，在那件事发生后有一个时刻，我心想：“好吧，这意味着我必须观看每一个他妈的镜头或者每一个场景。”对，对，对。
You know, it, I think, yeah, it's, for me, it's not like a definitive thought of like one or the other. I've also asked a bunch of people this question as well, but with all the... Are you single? Yeah. And what is your sign? And you're rising.
你知道的，我认为，是的，对我和来说，这不是那种非此即彼的绝对想法。我也问过很多人这个问题，但是带着所有的……你是单身吗？对。你的星座是什么？上升星座呢？
With the incredible directors that you've worked with, do you ever fantasize about cherry picking from each one of them and becoming a smoking director yourself? Yeah, sometimes, yeah. I mean, I thought originally that's what I kind of was more into like I came into acting from like making movies with friends
同你合作过的那些不可思议的导演们一起工作时，你有没有幻想过从他们每个人身上挑选优点，然后自己成为一个吸睛的导演？是的，有时候会。我是说，我最初以为那才是我更感兴趣的方向。我进入表演界是因为和朋友一起拍电影，
and doing that and yeah yeah I think about that sometimes yeah you'd be incredible please too you'd be great when you say thing about sometimes do you have an idea in your mind of something that's kind of back there I don't that's why I'm like until that thing happens where it's like I you know I think until
做那些事情，然后，是的，是的，有时候我会这么想。是的，你也会非常出色的，请吧，你也会很棒的。当你提到有时候时，你的脑海里有没有一个想法，比如某种退居幕后、尚未成型的念头？我没有，这就是为什么我会觉得……直到那件事情发生，比如我觉得……
that happens what scares me a little bit is just I'm incredibly indecisive as just a human being like even with a menu or with anything I get just crippled like I don't know so like someone being like
直到那件事发生之前，让我有点害怕的是，作为一个普通人，我极其优柔寡断。甚至面对菜单或者任何事情时，我都会彻底瘫痪，我不知道该怎么办。所以当有人问：“红衬衫还是蓝衬衫？”我就会说：“啊，我不知道……”但我想这也是一种对话，就像是“我不知道，区别在哪里呢？”所以这样去看待它，
red shirt or blue shirt I'd be like ah I don't know but but I guess it's also a conversation it's like I don't know what's the difference you know so kind of looking at it
也许这更多是一场对话，而不是一个决定，对吧，对吧，对吧？杰森，你是怎么做到的？我的意思是，曾经有人告诉我，说“我不知道”是可以的，
maybe it's more of a conversation than a decision is right right right how do you do that Jason I mean when somebody told me once it's okay to say you don't know
这让我轻松了很多。那其实是一个非常棒的回答。当他们带着上千个问题来找你时，你只需说：“我回头再回复你，给我一秒钟想想。”是的，这样做是可以的。是的，有很多……你是说在生活中吗，肖恩？是的，我知道，我是认真的。是的，是的，我认为这是非常重要的一生。我也这么做。当人们去索要答案时，我说：“好吧，有人告诉我，我没有义务按照他们的时间表回答他们。”没错，是的。我直到过去这十年才学会这一点，比如“我不知道，我不知道”。一年前，
it freed me up lot like that that's actually a great a great answer when they come to you with all the thousands of questions you just say I'm going to come back to you on that give me a second to think about that yeah it's okay to do that yeah it's it's a lot of the you mean in life shown you're saying yeah I know I mean it I'm being serious yeah yeah I think it's a really important life I do it too also when people go they want an answer I'm like well somebody told me like I don't have to answer them on their timeline that's right yeah I only learned it in like last 10 years where I don't know I don't know a year ago
我甚至不知道那个词是什么意思。我不知道你在说什么。你能重复一下你刚说的话吗？我不在乎了。但我想要回到……好吧，我不在乎被别人看作是这种人。是的，不，我明白你的意思。你知道的，这其实对我记不住别人的名字很有帮助。
I don't know what that word means. I don't know what you're talking about. Can you repeat what you just said? I don't care anymore. But I want to get back to, well, I don't care about being perceived as like this. Yeah, no, I understand what you're saying. Well, you know, that's actually helped me with the not remembering people.
比如，我会大胆地去猜，心里想“我想你的名字是这个”。哦，不。如果我猜错了，也没关系。他们会说：“不，不是凯茜。是梅丽莎。”然后我说：“抱歉。”我再往前迈一步，
Like, I just go out on a limb and I'll think, I think your name is this. Oh, no. If I'm wrong, it's okay. They say, no, it's not Kathy. It's Melissa. And I'm like, sorry. I go step forward.
奥斯卡，我再往前迈一步，我会说：“我觉得你的名字应该叫这个。”然后随便给个名字。等等，再聊点你的个人私事，奥斯卡，如果你不介意的话，比如你的妻子，埃尔维琳（Elvie）。她很漂亮，很有才华，是一位不可思议的纪录片导演。
I go a step further, Oster, I go, I think your name should be this. Sign a name. Wait, so a little more of your personal stuff, Oscar, if you don't mind, like your wife is this Elvierlin. She's beautiful, talented, incredible documentary filmmaker.
真的吗？是的，她太不可思议了。太不可思议了。而且她……我刚刚看了预告片，在研究你的作品、准备看《哈姆雷特国王》（King Hamlet）之前，我甚至都不知道这件事。我等不及要看了。那是你主演的……
Really? Yeah, she's incredible. Incredible. And she, I just saw the trailer, and I did not know this until I was researching you for King Hamlet, which I can't wait to watch. It's you playing.
那是什么？是关于戏剧《哈姆雷特》幕后制作的纪录片吗？它记录了你从排练到……不是吧？真的是这样吗？是的，所以那是2017年，发生了一连串疯狂的事情，
What is it? Is it the making of the play Hamlet and it's following you around about the process from rehearsal to... No way. Is that what it is? Yeah, so in 2017, it was this crazy confluence of things that happened
我母亲在2月份去世了。我们在3月份结婚。4月份，我们的第一个孩子出生了。然后在4月份，我开始为《哈姆雷特》排练，那是一个四个小时版本的《哈姆雷特》，一个我筹备了大约12年的项目。所以，她作为一名纪录片导演，当时刚生了宝宝，而且对于这一切不知该如何处理，你知道的，她也是从丹麦来的，突然被推入了这样一个完全不同的世界。她只是开始拿起摄像机进行拍摄。
where my mother passed away in February. We got married in March. In April, our first child was born. And in April, I started rehearsals for Hamlet, like this four-hour version of Hamlet. this thing that I was working on for like 12 years. And so her being a documentary filmmaker and having a new baby and like just kind of not knowing how to process this, you know, she's from Denmark too and she's kind of thrust
你知道的，在那之前，甚至在那之前我们也在拍摄。比如我会弹奏音乐，她会拍一些小音乐视频，然后我们把它们放到视频上之类的。所以这算是那种经历的自然延伸。于是她就开始拍摄了，因为最初的想法是她要拍摄这个项目的一部分幕后制作。
into this whole other world of stuff. She just started picking up a camera and started filming. You know, around that time before, before that we were also filming. Like I would play music and she would like film little music videos and we would put them on video and stuff. And so it was kind of a natural extension of that. And so she just started filming because the idea was she. She was going to film some of the making of this project.
当所有这些事情开始发生时，她就一直在拍。所以，当我回到母亲身边照顾临终关怀时，她也在场。我告诉她：“你知道的，我们能这样做的前提是，如果这个东西永远不见天日也没关系。”她回答说：“是的，当然，当然。我甚至不知道自己在做什么，我只是在拍，因为我不知道还能他妈的做些什么。”所以我们就是这么做的。她拍摄了整个过程，然后把它收了起来。
And when all this stuff started happening, she just kept filming. So, like, when I went down to my mom for hospice, she was kind of there. And I told her, you know, the only way we can do this is if it's okay if this never sees the light of day as well. And she said, yeah, of course, of course. I don't even know what I'm doing. I'm just filming because I don't know what the fuck else to do. And so that's what we did. And she filmed this whole process and then put it away.
然后大约一年前，她把硬盘拿出来开始查看，并和她合作过的一位优秀的剪辑师一起把它拼凑了起来。这真的很酷。然后她就剪出了一部非常漂亮的电影，关于我们所做的事情，对吧？也就是你如何面对生活，以及那些事情是如何交织在一起的。
And then about a year ago took out the hard drives and started looking through it and sort of piecing it together with her great editor that she's worked with. That's really cool. And then she kind of came up with this kind of beautiful movie about what kind of what we do, right? Which is like how you deal with your life
她有没有对你说：“嘿，还记得我们说过永远不见天日的那件事吗？我正在制作它。”她有没有告诉你她正在考虑……或者她先给你看了什么东西？她先给我看了点东西。
and how those things intertwine. Yeah. Did she say to you, hey, remember that thing we said we'd never show the light of day? I'm working on it. Did she tell you that she's thinking about... Or does she show you something first? She showed me something first.
她对我说：“嘿，我把这个东西拼凑起来了，你觉得这个怎么样？”然后我看过了，我说：“我不知道我怎么想，但继续做吧，你知道，继续做下去。”哦，那太酷了，而且她自始至终手里还抱着一个刚出生的婴儿。对，她听起来太不可思议了。我的……是的，她太不可思议了。而且也是她亲自掌镜的。这其实也非常搞笑，因为里面充满了各种事情发生的荒诞感。看着那些画面一定会有很强烈的脆弱感吧？
She's like, hey, I've been putting this thing. thing together what do you think of this and yeah and i watched it i was like i don't know what i think of that but keep going you know keep keep going oh that's really cool and with a newborn on her hip the entire time yeah she sounds incredible my yeah she's incredible yeah and she shot it as well and it's very it's very funny too because it's just it's the absurdity of everything that's happening and must have been very vulnerable to watch that yeah yeah to watch it again i mean i hadn't seen any of that footage especially with my mom and our family and, you know, it was, yeah, it was really, really intense, but really proud of her for doing it.
是的，是的，再次观看那些画面……我是说，我以前没看过任何那些素材，尤其是涉及我母亲和我们家庭的画面，你知道的，那真的是，非常非常强烈，但我为她能做到这一点感到非常骄傲。
How did you guys meet? Was it a Juilliard? No, no, no. She happened to be in New York working on something. Right. And it was like a movie she had finished and it was like some after party for it. And my manager at the time was like, you got to come to this party. And I was like, I'm not.
你们俩是怎么认识的？是在茱莉亚音乐学院吗？不，不，不。她当时正好在纽约做点项目。对。那是她刚拍完的一部电影，举行了一场庆功派对。我当时的经纪人对我说：“你必须去这个派对。”我说：“我不去。”
I am preparing for my Coen brothers' men. movie. I am not going to go to this thing. He's like, dude, there's this chick. You got it. You just got to come. And I was like, all right, but I'm going to go dressed as Lou and Davis. With my cat and my guitar. Yeah, well, this is before I had started, right? But I dressed in the outfit, and I was like, and I'm going to go, and I'm
“我在为科恩兄弟的电影做准备。我才不去那种地方。”他说：“老兄，那里有个女孩。你非去不可，你一定要去。”我说：“好吧，但我会打扮成路维·戴维斯（Louwyn Davis）的样子去，带着我的猫和吉他。”是的，好吧，那是开拍前的事了。但我穿着那套衣服，心想：“我要去那里，
going to try to do this thing where I can project warmth without smiling. I want to see if I can do it, you know? Or, like, tell a joke, but not laugh to let anybody know it's a joke, and let's see what happens. Wow. And so I went in, and And I was, like, sitting there with my fingerless gloves and eating and nobody else was eating. And her being, like, you know, a documentary and was like, who's this little brown weirdo, you know, in the corner?
我要尝试做到不笑也能流露出温暖。我想看看我能不能做到，你知道吗？或者，讲个笑话，但自己不笑，不让任何人知道这是个笑话，然后看看会发生什么。”哇。所以我就进去了，
And, like, comes over and starts talking to me. And then I told her I was a musician. No way. No way. Yeah, perhaps you've heard of the closet heterosexuals. At one point, she's like, I can't tell her you flirting with me. And I was like, yeah, yeah. I am.
然后我就坐在那儿，戴着露指手套吃东西，其他人都没有在吃。她作为一个纪录片导演，心想：“角落里这个棕皮肤的小怪人是谁啊？”然后她走过来开始跟我说话。接着我告诉她我是一名音乐家。不是吧？不会吧？是的，也许你听说过“隐蔽异性恋者（the closet heterosexuals）”乐队。有那么一瞬间，她说：“我看不出你是不是在调情。”我说：“对，对。我就是。”
Oh, that's good. I love that. So I started. Are you a cat guy? I'm sure you ask you. I bet they, but that was the question at the junket. That was the question.
哦，那太棒了。我太喜欢了。所以我开始了。你是个爱猫的人吗？我敢肯定别人也问过你这个问题。我打赌他们问过，那可是宣传活动上的经典问题。那是必问的问题。
Do you play guitar and are you a cat guy? It's so funny. Like a lot of these things I'm saying too, like I do realize there are anecdotes that I have said before and so. But they're new to us. It's funny like after you say, I don't know if you guys get this,
你弹吉他吗？你是个爱猫的人吗？太搞笑了。就像我刚才说的很多事情一样，我也意识到这些都是我以前说过好多次的轶事，所以……但对我们来说是新鲜的。有趣的是，在你讲完之后——我不知道你们有没有这种感觉，
but like saying anecdotes after a while, you feel like, I think I'm lying. Right. I've said this so much. I don't think this is true. Yeah, yeah, yeah. For sure. John, hang on Star Wars.
但讲完这些轶事一段时间后，你会觉得：“我觉得我在撒谎。”没错。这话我说得太多了，以至于我自己都觉得这不是真的了。对，对，对。肯定的。乔恩，等等，“星球大战”的事，
We'll get to it. I know that you can feel it. I know. I can't feel it. I know. I used to think that I could speak to cats, so I would, like, go to the backyard and, like, meow a lot, and cats would come. Hang on a second. Let's just pause in here for a second, Oscar.
我们一会儿就聊到。我知道你能感觉到。我知道。我甚至感觉不到了。我知道。我以前以为自己能和猫说话，所以我会去后院，学猫叫很多次，然后猫就会过来。等一下。我们在这里暂停一下，奥斯卡。
Go ahead and elaborate. That was it. It was just like. And they would come. That's why you liked the joke. That's why he liked that joke so much. I don't have a lot of time. Hit it with the sci-fi.
请继续详细说说。就那样。就是那样。然后它们就会过来。这就是你为什么那么喜欢这个笑话的原因。这就是为什么他那么喜欢那个笑话。我时间不多了。快切入科幻话题吧。
I don't have a lot of time. I got to get through this stuff because I want to know about ex machina. X. Machina incredible. Listen to me, I've seen it like 10 times. I know every line. Scotty and I quote it all the time. You know, we still go,
我时间不多了。我得赶紧把这些过一遍，因为我想了解《机械姬》（Ex Machina）。《机械姬》太不可思议了。听着，我都看过十遍了。每一句台词我都倒背如流。我和斯科蒂经常引用里面的台词。你知道的，我们现在还会说：“纪子，走吧（Kiyoko, go）”，对吧？这把我逗笑了。所以这部电影是2014年上映的。是的。
Kiyoko, go, right? That made me laugh. So it came out in 2014. Yeah. Can you believe the relevance it has today? yeah yeah i mean Alex garland he's just wild isn't it yeah yeah he keyed into this thing and
你能相信它在今天依然具有如此强的现实意义吗？对，对，对。我是说，亚力克斯·嘉兰（Alex Garland），他真是太疯狂了，不是吗？对，对，他切入了这一点，
even the way that we gather information you know he talked Nathan the character I play um talks about like well yeah you know I'm gonna I gather all the signals from all the cell phones and I get it all that's how I mean everything you talked about in the movie is happening right now yeah it's crazy yeah yeah I just
甚至包括我们收集信息的方式，你知道的，他谈到我扮演的角色内森（Nathan）时说：“哦，是的，你知道的，我要收集所有手机的信号，我把所有这些都弄到手……”这就是我的意思，你在电影里谈论的一切现在都在发生。是的，太疯狂了，对，对，我只是
yeah I wonder does that occur to you when you see stuff or you're reading stuff that's going on in the world and you go yeah yeah I was there yeah Yeah, but it felt like that when I read the script And then Alex Garland and I kept like talking about it working on And we would look at it from every angle And look at like the current You know, literature and everything that was going on at the time
对啊，我就想，当你看到这些东西，或者读到世界上正在发生的事情时，你会不会觉得“对，对，我当时就在那儿，对”？是的，但我读剧本的时候就有这种感觉。然后我和亚力克斯·嘉兰不断地讨论、打磨它，我们会从各个角度来看待它，看看当时的
And it just, it felt like completely locked in And yeah, it's amazing how it holds up Alex Garland is, I mean, this guy, I mean, right? Well, let's hope not all your films are Harbingers Dune is a pretty bleak look into our future but incredible film my god amazing and you're amazing in it and i did need to you get to all the you get all the great ones that you get to work with i read this i want you to tell the guys if you want to i can tell it which is one of the best pranks i've ever heard of on any film shoot on dune when you
时事、文学和所有正在发生的事情。它感觉完全契合，而且它经受住了时间的考验，这太神奇了。亚力克斯·嘉兰，我的意思是，这家伙，真是太厉害了，对吧？好吧，希望你的所有电影都不是某种不祥的预兆。《沙丘》对我们的未来是一个相当严峻的审视，但这是一部不可思议的电影。天哪，太棒了，你在里面的表现也太棒了。你总是能参与到所有伟大的作品中，和所有优秀的演员合作。我读到过这个，我想让你告诉大家——如果你愿意的话，我可以讲——这是我在任何电影拍摄现场听过的最棒的恶作剧之一。在拍摄《沙丘》时，你
after the nude scene speaking of dance belts speaking of dance belts go ahead you tell it well it's called what is it really called you call it a cock sock right well um um um Or a modesty sock? Modesty stock. Modesty stock. Not everybody calls of that, but yeah. I'm going to get it wrong, but you left your, so you did the scene and you had a, quote, modesty sock on, and you put it in Denise's jacket pocket.
在那个裸戏之后，说到舞蹈保护带（dance belts），说到舞蹈保护带，请继续，你来讲吧。好吧，这叫什么来着？你管它叫“鸡巴袜（cock sock）”，对吧？嗯……嗯……嗯……或者是“谦虚袜（modesty sock）”？谦虚袜。谦虚袜。不是每个人都这么叫，但对。我可能会说错，但你留下了你的……所以你拍完了那场戏，你穿着所谓的“谦虚袜”，你把它塞进了蒂莫西（Timothée）的夹克口袋里。
It's bright. His chest pocket. And he later pulled it out. Yeah, well, I left, and then I got a picture of him holding it like, what the fuck. At the dinner table. After the take, that's hilarious. And then he says this is true that MoMA asked for it. Oh, my God.
太显眼了。他的胸前口袋。他后来把它掏出来了。是的，好吧，我离开了，然后我收到了一张照片，是他拿着它，一脸“他妈的这是什么”的表情。在餐桌旁。拍摄结束之后，太搞笑了。然后他说，MoMA（纽约现代艺术博物馆）要求收藏这个，这是真的。哦，天哪！
Oh, really? Really? Well, they'd be smart to get it. Hopefully they got a wall big enough. Yeah, right? Good for you. Go for you. Go for you. Shoney, anything on Star Wars?
哦，真的吗？真的吗？好吧，他们要是真弄到手可就太明智了。希望他们有一面够大的墙。对吧？真为你高兴。真为你高兴。真为你高兴。肖恩，关于《星球大战》有什么想问的吗？
I mean, yeah, just the dumb question, the obvious question. Is it real a fan? Were you a fan? Wait, look at this. What's Darth Vader like in the morning? No, the basic questions. Were you a fan? Were you freaked out that you got the part?
我是说，是的，就是那个蠢问题，显而易见的问题。你真的是粉丝吗？你以前是粉丝吗？等等，看这个。达斯·维达（Darth Vader）早上是什么样的？不，最基础的问题。你是粉丝吗？你得到这个角色时被吓到了吗？
Like, was it, were you a huge fan as a kid? No, but my family were huge, huge fans, like collectors and, you know, my uncle in particular, it was massive, massive. Oh, wow. He loved making that phone call. Oh, man, that phone call was, oh, it was great. And he came, he was an extra a couple times,
就像是，你小时候就是超级大粉丝吗？不是，但我的家人是超级、超级粉丝，就像收藏家一样，尤其是我的叔叔，简直是狂热级别的。哦，哇。他打那个电话的时候肯定爽极了。哦，天哪，那个电话，哦，太棒了。他甚至来当过好几次群众演员，
I remember I brought him and he died a couple years ago which was so rest in peace but it was the most amazing thing like I brought him and I couldn't find him and he was like in Carrie Fisher's trailer just like hanging out
我记得我把他带去了，后来他几年前去世了，愿他安息。但那是最神奇的事情，我把他带到片场，结果我到处找都找不到他，最后发现他竟然在凯丽·费雪（Carrie Fisher）的化妆车里跟人家聊天呢。
yeah that's crazy to me that's crazy I mean Scottie and I just visited the set of the new Star Wars movie with Sean Levy directing when I was in London and we got to go to the creature shop I mean we that's like everything we're for
是的，这对我来说太疯狂了，太疯狂了。我是说，当我在伦敦时，斯科蒂和我刚刚参观了由肖恩·利维（Shawn Levy）执导的新《星球大战》电影的片场，我们还去了怪物道具作坊。我是说，那简直就是我们梦寐以求的一切。
I don't know if you're into that but I was just like It's so cool that you were part of the reboot of this franchise. You were the first part of the reboot. I mean, it's wild. And look at where it's at now. It's like last night at the dinner table, Jason and we're all sitting around.
我不知道你是不是也喜欢这些，但我当时就觉得，你能成为这个重启系列的一部分真是太酷了。你是这个重启系列的第一部分。我是说，这太疯狂了。看看它现在发展到什么地步了。就像昨晚在餐桌旁，杰森和我们大家坐在一起，
And out of nowhere, I go, has anybody seen the trailer from Mandalorian and Grogo? Just silence. Except I said, I've seen it, and it's fantastic. Yes, I can't wait to see that movie. And didn't you say, yeah, that you have not seen the trailer or you refuse to see the trailer? Me? No, God, I saw it like 10 times.
莫名其妙地，我突然说：“有人看过《曼达洛人与古古》（Mandalorian and Grogu）的预告片了吗？”全场一片寂静。除了我说：“我看过了，太棒了。”是的，我等不及要看那部电影了。你不是说过吗，是的，你还没看过预告片，或者你拒绝看预告片？我？不，天哪，我都看过十遍了。
No, no, no, no, I saw it. I love it. Oh, no, no, there was a guy I was with yesterday said that he will not see it yet because it'll get his, he won't see it until it's closer to release because he's just going to get too excited. You can't sustain the excitement level. Yeah. All right, rapid fire before we let you go, ready?
不，不，不，不，我看过了。我太喜欢了。哦，不，不，昨天和我在一起的一个人说他现在还不想看，因为这会让他……他要等到快上映时再看，因为他会变得太兴奋了。你无法长时间保持那种兴奋程度。好吧，在我们放你走之前来个快问快答，准备好了吗？
Yeah. If we were roommates for a week, what would be the one Oscar Isaac Cork that would drive me insane and what's the one that I would love? Do you cook? Sean, look at you. I don't really cook. I mean, I can cook, but I don't cook a lot. So Sean's not happy with that.
准备好了。如果我们当一周的室友，我会疯掉的奥斯卡·伊萨克的怪癖是什么？我会喜欢的是什么？你会做饭吗？肖恩，你看你。我其实不做饭。我是说，我会做，但我做得不多。所以肖恩对这个回答不满意。
What would he love? Oh, God. You wouldn't love that I don't cook very much. What would you love? Theater stories. Theater stories, hugs. I'm very affectionate. Oh, he loves a hug.
他会喜欢什么？哦，天哪。你不会喜欢我不太会做饭这一点。那你回喜欢什么？戏剧故事。戏剧故事，拥抱。我非常喜欢跟人亲近。哦，他可太喜欢拥抱了。
There you go. Appropriate, unnecessary. Yeah. Impromptu hugs. Cots, hug, hugs. Cots, hugs. Who's most likely to win in a board game? You, Jessica Chastain, or Ethan Hawke?
就是这样。得体或不必要的。是的。即兴拥抱。小床，拥抱，拥抱。小床，拥抱。谁最有可能在桌游中获胜？你、杰西卡·查斯坦（Jessica Chastain）还是伊桑·霍克（Ethan Hawke）？
Oh, I guess it depends on the board game. But, you know, it's Scrabble. Oh, it's Scrabble. Sure. I'm going to go with Ethan, because, you know, he's like a poet and a writer, and he's just, you know, that's a seasoned, individual, man. I know, me too. He's so incredible that thing.
哦，我想这取决于玩什么桌游。但是，如果是拼字游戏（Scrabble）。哦，那是拼字游戏。当然。我选伊桑，因为，你知道的，他就像个诗人兼作家，而且他只是，你知道的，那是一个阅历丰富的成熟男人。我知道，我也是。他简直太棒了。
Yeah, love him. And I love that you, I read that you improvised for your two sons. No, why? You just sit there with a guitar and you just, make up song for them? I did. Well, now, it's funny because I did that for a while,
是的，非常喜欢他。我喜欢你……我看到报道说你为你的两个儿子即兴创作歌曲。没有，为什么？你只是坐在那里拿着吉他，然后为他们编歌吗？我以前会。好吧，现在，很有趣，因为我那样做了一段时间，
and then they were like, please stop. They got old enough to say stop. Yeah, they just didn't like whenever I would play guitar or sing, and that went away for a bit, but recently in the last year, I just bought this looper pedal.
然后他们就开始说：“请停下。”他们长到会说“停下”的年纪了。是的，只要我弹吉他或唱歌，他们就表现得很不喜欢，这种情况持续了一段时间。但最近这一年里，我刚买了这个循环踏板（looper pedal）。
So, like, we've got this, you know, just kind of show you a little bit. We've got, like, old drums here. Oh, look at this. And like guitars, there's the looper pedal down there. Oh, yeah, that's a lot of piano over there. Yeah. And so we've got this.
所以，就像我们现在这样，你知道的，稍微展示一下。我们这里有旧鼓。哦，看这个。还有吉他，循环踏板就在那下面。哦，对，那边还有一架钢琴。是的。所以我们现在有了这个。
We've just been making a lot of music together. How old are they? He's going to turn six. Mads is going to turn six on Sunday, and Eugene is eight. Oh, my God. Yeah. Prime time. I know.
我们最近一起创作了很多音乐。他们多大了？他快六岁了。马兹（Mads）周日就满六岁了，尤金（Eugene）八岁了。哦，天哪！是的。正是好玩的年纪。我知道。
That's so good to get them into that young. Sean, how old are we doing you start playing piano? Five. Really? There you go. What do they, do they, have they seen Dad's movies or anything? Yeah. Yeah, they've seen some of them.
能让孩子们这么小就接触这些，真的太棒了。肖恩，你几岁开始学钢琴的？五岁。真的吗？你看。他们，他们看过爸爸的电影之类的吗？看过。看过，他们看过其中几部。
They've seen Star Wars. Eugene's actually asked me about Star Wars yesterday. How were they with the notes? Are they kind with the notes? They're a little tough with the notes, I've got to say. Kids are tough. I can't say enough about you and Frankenstein. I just think it's an incredible performance.
他们看过《星球大战》。尤金昨天还问过我关于《星球大战》的事。他们对评价严厉吗？他们对评价友好吗？我得说，他们的评价有点苛刻。小孩子要求很严格。我对你和《科学怪人》赞不绝口。我真的觉得这是一场令人难以置信的表演。
It just blew me away. I can't say enough about you and everything. I know. It's true, awesome. You were fantastic and you were very nice to join us. Yeah, you're really, really cool. Thanks, guys. And Will, I can't wait to see what you did in that movie, man.
这简直让我大开眼界。我对你和一切都赞不绝口。我知道。真的，太棒了。你太棒了，而且你能来参加我们的节目真的很好。是的，你真的很酷。谢谢你们。还有威尔，我迫不及待地想看你在那部电影里的表现了，兄弟。
Yeah. He's so good. Wait, do you see that? He and Bradley just rocked it. Thanks, man. No, you're one of the great. You're one of our greats, man, for real. Yeah, Oscar, and you're a great dude.
是的。他太棒了。等一下，你看到了吗？他和布拉德利简直演绝了。谢谢，兄弟。不，你是最伟大的之一。你真的是我们最伟大的人之一，兄弟。是的，奥斯卡，你是个好人。
We hung out a couple times. You're such a great dude. It's so good to see you, man. Yeah, great to see you. Thank you for being here, man. Enjoy the rest of your day. Good luck with Frankenstein. We're all going to go see it.
我们一起出去过几次。你真是个好人。很高兴见到你，兄弟。是的，很高兴见到你。谢谢你来到这里，兄弟。祝你今天过得愉快。《科学怪人》祝你好运。我们都会去看的。
All right. Thank you, Oscar. Thanks, buddy. Thanks, guys. Thanks, Oscar. Bye, pal. Bye Well, that was tough saying
好的。谢谢你，奥斯卡。谢谢，老兄。谢谢，伙计们。谢谢，奥斯卡。再见，老朋友。再见。好吧，要对
Good Night to Oscar there I could talk to him forever Oh my God He's in so many of my favorite movies I mean that X Machina is just incredible But wait do you see Frankenstein I can't wait Everything that guy does
奥斯卡说晚安可真难，我可以跟他聊一整天。天哪，他演了那么多我最喜欢的电影。我是说，那部《机械姬》简直太棒了。但是等等，你看了《科学怪人》吗？我等不及了。那家伙做的每一件事
Is so incredible I know how is somebody so good I know he's so good it's all I have to say I'm like blown away I'm literally we're all thinking here about all these different performances you're like oh yeah he's so good at that
都太不可思议了。我知道，怎么会有人这么优秀？我知道他太优秀了，这就是我要说的全部。我简直惊呆了。我literally，我们大家都在这里想着所有这些不同的表演，你会想，哦对，他那个演得太好了
oh he's so good in that yeah do you think it's something in the water at Juilliard or do you think they come in I think they do a pretty good job of vetting and you know but what we should do is we should do an episode where we have the people from Juilliard who never did shit
哦他那个演得太好了，对，你觉得这是因为茱莉亚音乐学院的水土好，还是你觉得他们进来的时候——我觉得他们在选拔方面做得相当不错，你知道的，不过我们应该做一期节目，请那些从来没红过的茱莉亚音乐学院的人
we are bright right to have them on or the people that didn't make it in or the people who didn't make it was us so there's a there's a first three there's the first three doesn't get shittier than us and then yeah do you think they do like do you think they teach people musicals and and uh jilliard like what like can you think of any of the top of your your head like maybe like bye bye birdie yeah why do you commit to it oh bye bye bye birdie that was a really short outro Smartless.
请他们来不是很合适吗，或者那些没考进去的人，或者那些没考进去的就是我们，所以这里有前三个人，前三个人没有比我们更逊的了，然后呢，你觉得他们会教人们音乐剧吗，呃，在茱莉亚，比如什么，你能随便说出一个吗，比如《再见，小鸟》？对，你为什么这么投入？哦，《再见，小鸟》，那是一个非常短的尾声，Smartless。
Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless。Smartless 是由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjarf 和 Bennett Barbico 100% 有机手工制作的。Smartless。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。